thank you
[Music]
foreign
what's going on love y'all love y'all
y'all have no idea just the beefiest
Lord the beef is here
love y'all y'all have no idea I'm
feeling glorious right now feeling great
everything is great let's do some roll
calls you know what I'm saying Mandingo
mcstickins no doubt lots of privacy was
going on web Dave yo web Dave I
appreciate you brother I appreciate you
how you holding it down behind the
scenes we're gonna make things happen
trust just crazy weeks crazy weeks Zach
Riley was going off the OG General back
in the building salute no doubt so I
gotta read your members shout out to the
gray beans in the building we outside we
them boys all hail to IOP salute the
Lords the end is near xw oh okay I see
what we do it yo BT Maverick what's up
goes fix the what's going on you know
that Lydia Master what's up and turtle
[__] I was going on how my levels are
sounding am I sounding okay yeah we
holding a lot of Pop not we in here you
already know it is Zach rally what's
going on Salute yo hustle bro all right
listen I know I know I love you bro I
love you bro I appreciate you you have
no idea what's up though salute salute
you know what it is like I said that's
the theme that's the thing right now you
know what I'm saying I'm gonna throw a
party for you I gotta throw a party for
my day ones being in the studio but they
lace up God y'all showed me a lot when a
brother you know what I'm saying that's
what's up man it meant a lot it meant a
lot we got some fun a lot to talk about
you know what I'm saying so um some of
them might have a little issue might be
coming in hot you know a little later he
had a work issue so we're gonna figure
that out we got some things cooking the
topics I know yeah some of y'all are
here the things on Twitter and other
things yeah I know what y'all here for
I will address some of it but we ain't
gonna get too too deep but um yeah but I
appreciate y'all just overall like I
appreciate y'all this was a a good
weekend
um yeah you know we just got set record
straight to certain things and stuff
like that but at the end of the day
we're moving with love we're moving with
peace you know King is more Malcolm I'm
more Martin I'm with my Martin right now
you know what I'm saying because you
know sometimes you gotta you gotta bring
people together bring things together
you can you can learn from things so um
yeah his beefy Cog season Ultra that's
right it's extra beef right now
no doubt but yo we got some fun um good
topics looking forward to this and uh
we're on the ego we know we're on the
Eva of decisions you know next week FTC
thing gonna be crazy man it's a lot
going on so I'm excited for these topics
we're you know kind of the Calm before
the storm you know so it is what it is
send the kaboot send them to the boys to
another one
[Music]
it's good to see you on our game gotta
throw a party for my day was staying in
the studio but they gonna lay some I
love y'all I know it the real ones know
what I'm talking about with the
subliminal right now yeah I mean it
means a lot and trust me a lot I saw a
lot this week and it really I made a
brother tear up my yo thank God you know
what I'm saying so I feel good I'm
blessed blessed as far as what's going
on I see you check your damn phones I
hit you
um yeah a little beefy said you know but
look we're gonna get we're running a
little late oh I see attic pulled up in
the casting couch attic you want to talk
to them
I don't know what he doing all right can
you hear me now yeah there you go there
you go so you run a little late so
what's going on man I see it see the cat
the couch looking looking all nice you
good yeah I think this is my name
I was talking to soft we're gonna put
another another poster right here
uh and then I'm gonna have to get
something for
the this is these are but the glance it
needs I need to get like something to
put it over the window
anyway
look we're gonna be back we don't know
when I'm coming in hot King's coming so
I don't want to get uh hit with the
strike does he coming in with music yeah
you better hurry up yeah but hurry up
now you can't pick up trouble
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
for your original y'all too Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rains you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all feel Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Sample and making it flammable this
is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social or my city
but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still in
my Coastal I got you this was dead
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
now
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got you
man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
foreign
welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the rain you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter social or
my city but I'm still by Coastal I got
it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start with
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social lower my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep
detrimental to an elemental was an
avatar to a knee vendor I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny word to
carnido who cares if he flies you still
a mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be civil you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that joke can't
ever still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this and you're cubicle on the lawyers
day
[Music]
radio radio
hat makes it gonna be hot in my check
and all of that we first you know what I
gotta I gotta check my my sound levels
because we got to come in you know we
got some stuff to talk about
sounding good sounded good you heard you
got hurt no and I put the white to go
with the white beans doing clean okay we
go okay we're doing okay because what
you know the white and gold royalty you
know I what I had to do is this today is
about you know washing dudes in the
length of Minnetonka
gotta clean them up somebody gotta get
washed up oh man my motto is I gotta
throw a party for my day once then in
the studio over there lay something
that's my motto I'm blessed I'm feeling
good but anyway how y'all doing what's
going on attic is like what is it going
on yeah yeah I love honestly the only
fans angle yeah yeah right now yeah
wine for like five minutes on stuff I
don't care too much about
look at that look yo did you see his
latest video when you turned around in
the chair like he tried to do it
I can't see the couch addict is lit
cancer
I'm like yo you know what it is I like
the effect of oh no as Alex is having on
yeah
I I will admit uh some of that little
bit has come from a little Alex what I
want to do is uh me and Saul were
talking put one more poster between
these two oh man and then like every
three or four months I'm gonna I'm going
to
replace all three it's like you got
people coming through to see you hey
we're gonna move on here you hear you
and we are live and welcome to the
islands podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 312.
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the round table on the Lord's date
and today we've got Xbox's presents at
Gamescom Red Dead Redemption remastered
Peter molynews new project
and Final Fantasy 16 remastered to
discuss so we gonna get right into it
you said Final Fantasy remastered well
you know the Final Fantasy 16 sales I
should say
I was like I kind of tried to flip and
see if you catch it but I was like yeah
we remastered it but I know we talk
about it
I ain't talking about
so let's introduce the four a week yeah
we missing a horse man can we send some
love to Lord Sovereign
[Laughter]
has some things going on you know he may
be able to join us he may not if not
I know you got a lot going on but uh
let's introduce the original Lords of
the round my calls with the code most my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf I
don't like his face my man Lord addict
from the attic so why do you have that
face sir
what's going on guys I have that face
because I want to have that face
yeah tell the true shame the devil
have any type of face he chooses to have
oh look at that right so as you guys can
see there's a thunder of my new uh video
that's gonna go uh live straight after
the show I'm breaking every Xbox Studio
from on a s to an A to B to C what's
funny is the the last tier is D and I
was I'm gonna put him in the D Spot as I
will give him a d rating and I'm like
and I was like I wish I'd have named
that something else yeah yeah D Gonna
Get You
that's my video that's gonna go live
straight after the podcast is that D
beefy
I woke up in the morning I said um I'm
looking at the Timeline I said oh snap
I had to screenshot it and send it to
the chat I was like I can't co-sign this
until the kid get up
I said I don't know who he out with this
one
it was a little racy oh man shout out to
my man what's this what's over today
dread Trinity I forgot Hobie did I got a
shout about it she probably in the chat
what I'm gonna say is this if y'all want
to know what uh corporate Card
corporate slash beefy
you gotta go on cog's timeline because
he you know he tagged he just put it
behind me oh no we don't even do that
we don't need to do that we all need to
do all that
all right his name is official young
dreads let's get let's get it right yeah
shout out to the young king you know
what I'm saying he's doing a lot of work
out here I like his stuff his freestyle
workers what's up freestyle but uh this
video will go live straight after
podcasts are going to premiere on my
channel and I will send you guys over
there I'll rate my own channel
hope you guys enjoy it yes I I will be
up front blizzard Studios as part of
this King because that's how confident
we are I that holding the line
bro
I heard I heard we supposed to be
getting information within the next 48
hours I mean yeah information we're the
whole thing I know what it is y'all know
it is so that's been an attic that's
what's going on yeah so that's pretty
much it and definitely go over there and
what this video took me like two days
worth of editing like it's ridiculous
because I had to like find the videos I
I'm trying new styles of editing this
video took me a long time to edit and
one thing I want to shout out to the
community I made a video yesterday I
didn't think was going to do anything
and that that's that's almost a ten
thousand views
getting like the 130 subs off of it yeah
it it that video was cool it was just
mainly be like yo why is Activision they
they popping bottles for no reason let's
talk about it there are a couple people
that's like addict you're trying to give
the illusion that it's passed I was like
no I literally said in the title Xbox
uh Xbox One the court hearing because
Activision's popping bottles early for
some reason so I I get it you know but
that attic chair spin yeah this fit it's
crazy
yeah yeah so that's just a little crazy
but anyway that's pretty much it and of
course no sub hopefully maybe later
maybe we'll see I'll take over his
technical but of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the access
gamer oh the prophet of Xbox Swami King
of the statues there is nothing less
than that premium experience and is the
leader of the whole the line movement oh
beloved Lord King how we doing all right
before I get started man I'm doing
fantastic but I want to give a shout out
to uh Jaron boots in this last night he
fought uh Villa and uh the last time we
saw Villa is when he fought speedy
rashidi and wait hold money
yeah yeah that's that's probably one of
the dope
you don't speak between your hands it's
quick
um
so so
um he beat speedy and the dude is an
Argentinian and he's grinded out uh dude
and boots is the next in line uh he's
The Heir Apparent to the the 147th
Division the Walter weight division you
know we have uh the combination of
um
and you know Showtime just dropped the
the the the two-part episodes of uh like
building up to the fight Camp uh for
that but while that was happening boots
was fighting Villa and this is probably
one of the toughest fights that he ever
had and in my opinion this was the the
litmus test for him for me to see who he
was
both of them to me well both of them is
undefeated you have uh boots that has
um no decision on on his record and
Villa who had a loss but that loss
wasn't real if you sort of fight you'd
be like wow yeah yeah so but the date
the battle of the two undefeated wifey
and I was watching it and Boots started
hitting Villa with some shots and he
refused to go down and I said babe she's
like oh my God what's going on and I was
like you got to teach a man how to lose
um you gotta show him I'm gonna break
you you're not when when you don't know
how to lose yeah you're not gonna go
down easy because you're a teacher you
got somebody got to know yeah submit you
know you got you gotta push that button
but um Villa held on man to as long as
he could and you know boots knocked them
out eventually
um it was such a brutal great fight so
anybody that getting didn't get a chance
to see a go watch Showtime last night it
was a great fight no doubt now
haven't pulled this out in a minute oh
we fraud a lot what's happening what
what's happening what's happening oh man
yo you know
well before to learn what's going on let
me change my watch oh we changing the
watch too oh no this is epic something
well we well funded
yo it's Millions over here bro bro
put the green on put the money green
ones since I'm purchased by the Green
Team yeah attic we well funded bro yeah
we're well funded
all right so let me let me start this
off with saying this let's get it and
this is not me to my own horn or to my
podcast on home right talk no podcasts
that do what we do
none the reason that is is because we're
well funded yeah definitely
that is very true and it says things yes
it's
and I'm gonna tell you take your best
part your your favorite podcast put your
favorite podcast against what I'm about
to say let's go
we go out to each and every show
and it's because we dig in our own
Pockets right now in the beginning
it was digging your own Pockets until we
can get someplace in any startup
business and listen to what I'm saying
to you this is a startup business you're
going to lose money in the beginning so
what we would do we would pull out pull
our money together because we work jobs
we will pull our money together and go
buy shirts and all the merch used to
come through me before and I used to
logistically put it out so when we
decided to spend two thousand five
hundred dollars plus spend upwards
thousands going out to California Oaks
to get into Fan Fest and hand out shirts
to go to E3 to see everybody just to be
seen prank calling the shirts were like
five thousand dollars
but we gave them out facts I don't hear
nobody saying yo um they was well funded
then right I didn't I didn't because we
wasn't as popular then that's why we
weren't well funded right but see but we
still had the same stuff we have in our
backgrounds and stuff right
um when dealing them told us yo step
your mic game up yeah yeah whatever we
got no it was Luca no it was the other
two it was a dealer yeah because I
remember Lucas the one that's like okay
Dillard gave us constructive criticism
you could skip that it just shamed us
everybody everybody teaches in their own
way facts right so if um but see Dylan
what I like when somebody says something
that you're doing wrong
tell me how to do it right right right
so what dealer did was tell me how to do
it right correct right so I Gotta Give
mad respect to the dealer games look at
the RDX my whole strategy for this
podcast and let me tell you why I'm the
marketing manager my whole strategy for
this podcast was to make sure that we
were seen one two develop individual
personalities three get the bags
I'm not here to to do the two-step with
you I don't know if you ain't checked
it's just a great bit
um I'm gonna head to do the two-step I'm
here to get the bag for the team I want
these dudes to never have to get up and
punch a clock again I want this to be a
hundred percent what it is so when we're
going through this stuff right and let's
say let's just say you're an exec and
you look over and you see these same
people that I strategically made sure
these shirts stand out I strategically
made sure that everybody has their name
on I strategically make sure that we
have we are on camera these cameras cost
a boatload of money in each one every
last one of us got one Mike said
everything gets I think the
the mics is like
1100 lows 900 a pop yeah and everything
went back into the podcast
the camera is like 14 with everything
with it like whatever's donated is put
back in
Okay so
but we do it because we understand the
main goal is to give you the best
quality that you can receive so for
somebody to come out and say that we are
getting a bag from some place an
invisible bag I wish it was a bad
because I would tell you automatically
like I told you before that no one's
doing this full time
right so when you say Xbox is fun first
of all Cog don't rock with Xbox like
that
addict don't rock with Xbox like that
Sovereign don't rock with Xbox Sovereign
is like it's not about our hard work our
commitment our grinding it's about we're
bought by someone and that's how we rise
is it disrespect because actually you
just saying me I'm the only bot here bro
right so what she's trying to say is oh
King is purchased no I told you when
Aaron gave me
um what is The Game Pass I'm I'm open
and honest but I also if XBox does
something wrong I give them that smoke I
seen you do it honestly all the time I'm
not gonna let her go for Bonnie when I
know the real what was going on over
there but she didn't went in on the Halo
Infinity but I did go in on her on the
situation because Heavies they had to
wear the crown right you got to be
respectful correct but I don't want you
to think you're gonna you're gonna tear
apart what we put together we work very
very hard we're going to Pax West this
year tell me your podcast is going there
um y'all podcast your favorite podcast
likes to regurgitate information that is
fed to them from another site from
someplace else because they always
citing oh I saw this or or I said this
we go out y'all ask for whatever
developers is and we go to those games
we go to get those developers these guys
work so hard in the background to get
developers on the show factual
we don't have a hundred thousand
subscribers so to have all the
interviews and stuff that we do have
much above our weight we punch above our
weight swinging we give back to
everybody in the community Dallas all
those bars that you hear in the
beginning he's from our community
just just to clarify no one that does
any form of commission for us is it's
off the free like we pay everything
we pay everyone and most of the time
most of the time they get paid more than
they ask because it's like you did a
good job Sean LaBrie so you can ask
anybody about see and this is why you
probably hear we well funded because you
don't hear anybody say you know the iron
Lord stiffed us you ain't never heard
that story
I mean you just look oh you know where's
all those super chats and stuff uh it's
called Washington State we all live on
the east coast those tickets are cheap
they're like 800 a pop or something like
that like it's just like look like we
always reinvest into ourselves shout out
to Alex what chat I'll see you I gotta
give her respect to Alex I watched your
video that's why I shared it out and
said dope because regardless to what he
saw through all the BS and he gave
credit where credit was due think about
it bro
he's been doing this since the press
start dating before that
and I love and real quick Alex you gotta
lay off my man dirt's Mike yeah
yeah it's just like dirt's put a lot of
time into this it's like you gotta lay
them all off
I love our community that we built so
yeah y'all can go at us for the the
Fanboy stuff Alex wants to end call you
want to let him know
I'm just asking before I just appreciate
it yeah we could let Alex say I just
gotta I gotta get kick off and I gotta
pause
you gotta look at it from an exact
standpoint if that keeps seeing the same
team in every uh place that they go to
in every convention and every show they
didn't expect to see us at the award
show but we showed up and we showed up
in in Iron Lord's fashion we take
pictures with these exacts
just to let them know that our presence
is here business is always open so if
you're ready to purchase the podcast
right and then I will let you know how
well-funded we are after the fact but
until then please respect my grind don't
tell me that I'm a paid chill and don't
sit there but like yo you shield for
free I'm actually giving you
entertainment this is what it's about so
I'm giving you five hours of
entertainment you tell me any place on
this planet that you can click into
something for five hours get entertained
and don't have to pay anything all we
want you to do is like follow And
subscribe that's it if you Super Chat we
super leaders appreciate it and we know
we read all this super Jazz let's call
that out facts you stay here an hour 45
minutes later yes sometimes because
we're so extra about making sure all of
your guys's worries are heard where you
guys literally Hold Us hostage I I don't
like that when they do that because
sometimes I'll be gotta get out of here
but listen I I just want to say it's
disingenuous to disrespect somebody's
grind somebody's hard work you know
because a lot of times we get into
arguments and fight because we got
personal lives so oh you're going out
again oh you're doing another podcast
again or you're doing this again first
yeah babe I got to do this because this
is I need to get here you know or or
when I'm at one of these shows and I'm
dm'ing whoever to ask me like let's say
Sith Lord wants to see a game King is
this game they ask us okay I'm gonna go
get that let me go get to that developer
um did you get any information on
Wrestle Quest oh hold on let me go get
that let me go make sure I get that
interview so there's a personal
connection or if I'm on the game ain't I
don't see none of y'all talking about oh
I spoke to so and so on on set game no
I'm playing all the time Jump in let's
play so far like oh let's go do this oh
let's do that
all I'm saying is please don't discount
our grind and our level of commitment to
this community
disrespectful telling us we're taking a
bag and we're shielding for a company
because then you all you really doing is
saying it to me personally because none
of these dudes here represent the Xbox
one ain't nobody here
you literally they feel a day like we
was like yo what's yeah like and I don't
I rock with Phil I want y'all to
understand respect for saving uh um a
console that I love facts
I recognize how great it was and the
obstacles that he was up against that
gay that allowed him to gain those names
he earned each and every last name so
when dudes think is a is a joke oh no
Aurelius is the golden one he he he did
that he saved the platform the platform
is viable now y'all are unfair of other
things but I've only bought here bro
we'll have to break the protocol we
gotta break protocol you don't have to
read that card oh man let me let's play
with each other's joysticks for five
dollars I'm one soft kind of man but
beefy Cog was mighty irresistible don't
tempt me Kyle
yo y'all crazy with this video other
than that this week what I've been
playing
playing playing fortnite playing my Rog
you know I gotta you know I gotta keep
this I gotta keep my my PC life go
inside right you know what I like about
this when when I log into this and I go
to my game pass I get the extra reward
points are you playing on your PC are
you playing on the go you pulled up the
app I was like oh snap for real so I go
in there and get my reward points this
they still gotta work on the user
interface and I gotta ask you a question
um like like do I got to put a fast SSD
in this joint you could put a you could
put a strong SSD in it for sure yeah you
can put it here internally but you gotta
do the surgery that's what I recommend I
wouldn't do that the micro SD because
they apparently they're breaking them
yeah I heard his issues with the heat
because the way the heat flows up the
top so yeah yeah I'll show you I'll show
you the videos Dumb easy six screws
Pop That Joint open boom it's the same
thing like the PlayStation I got a pop
over gotta rip the wings rip the wings
um anyway so there's a village okay so I
got that to do
um I played Final Fantasy if anybody
watched my twitch stream on Final
Fantasy I played it I'm sorry I did not
hear me talking I thought you'll be able
to talk through the stupid controller uh
that's another thing I don't I never
brought headsets for my PlayStation
because I'm not a dude to play
multiplayer games what do you mean these
heads up yeah exactly see those right
there I never brought those but those
come with a mic addict
yeah it's the most ghetto mic ever it's
not a mic like it's a directional mic
built into the headset like it sounds
horrible it sounds horrible like and
what's funny is like it has one of those
you know adapters that you plug into the
PlayStation yeah and to my knowledge so
far because I haven't really checked the
menus they might have changed it but you
can't play the audio from whatever
device you're going towards and the
headset at the same time so if you're
streaming on the PlayStation because on
Xbox you could do that you could tell
the Xbox play through the speakers and
play to the headset at the same time but
if you do it on Xbox on Playstation they
uh you know Elgato cards and stuff that
when I use an Elgato card it only picks
up what's on the audio so if it's in my
headset it's not in the audio so I have
to literally I can't use that headset
when I stream I have to I have to put it
on my monitor and then I have to hook up
a uh I sound like a lot yeah
it sounds like something stupid so um
anyway when y'all see me playing on and
I'm on Twitch on on doing PlayStation
y'all not gonna hear me talking all
right because why PlayStation stupid
um and they don't allow you to press a
button and just get in and have great
access yeah right but um I did the Final
Fantasy I'm I'm gonna have to side with
um attic on this okay what's up uh it
don't feel like Final Fantasy okay it
doesn't and maybe I'm the turn based
dude like I love how Dragon Quest is and
all these other games maybe I'm that guy
maybe I'm just this the the genre itself
Final Fantasy itself has moved past me
as a player but it doesn't feel like
Final Fantasy yeah maybe it could be a
spin-off game but I do hope they go back
to a turn base on something like just
just ahead give us something give us old
heads uh that feel that Final Fantasy
field so I was playing that and
um I went on to uh play a couple of
games like Unbound on Game Pass because
that came about yeah went back because
I'm playing Rog and I was I was like um
I'm stuck on Horizon on this for some
weird reason like Horizon look like yeah
it was looking really good on it really
not it doesn't even make any sense I'm
just like I'm but the battery life
helped me yeah that battery life is it I
gotta walk around with a charger but
um loving that and the last but not
least I see Alex
I played uh tears of the Kingdom you
know me and my son and you know had a
great time with that but other than that
I've been playing Twitter like I
normally do
um
I know I had a bug thank you guys for
telling me that it was the lantern bug
um all right so this is an invasive
species we're going to the house me and
wifey and son and I said I thought it
was a ladybug on the wall but he looked
like he got splatted like somebody like
shot him or something like his wings was
all wild so I was like what the hell is
up with this ladybug I said that's not a
ladybug I said that's a bug trying to
look like it's a ladybug and I said let
me take the picture so I took the
picture didn't think nothing of it
didn't kill the bug right I should have
killed the bug after I got the
information I thought dude was just
trolling me all right they said this is
the most dangerous invasive
right and and they said this species
will destroy all crops trees and
everything in the area behind your house
it would turn King into a PlayStation
fan
you look like Spider-Man it looked like
Spiderman so what they said to and if
you go to the invasive species website
they said kill it with fire
I'm not a lion he's looking outside for
this thing what's the bug called what is
it called it's called the lantern
lanternfly I'm I'm I'm a I'm a lantern
bug this this thing on the screen let me
let me keep it there for a second that
all right so that red black that's the
that's the evil that okay yeah that's
the evil that man who spotted lanternfly
yeah spotted lanternfly
most invasive species
that was on my house
um it's native to China poses a serious
economic threat to multiple U.S
Industries including vitaculture fruit
trees ornamentals and Timber
yo are we are we gonna burn your house
down is that what's going on yo they
said they said if you'll find a nest
burn it
so I was literally supposed to call um
like instant control oh wow did they
tell you to call these places he said if
you see it um report it because we
haven't seen one in 25 years in North
America you know King calls and reports
it and they confiscate his house that's
why I kept my mouth shut I hope nobody
reports me on Twitter
yeah that's what I've been up to no
before I get into my intro we got the
legendary oh no it's Alex in the
building yeah a little different it's
not like it's coming from another source
I don't know you know probably that blue
yeti good or does it sounded bad yeah it
sounded like you was going that riggity
back
it might it might be a blue jay yeah
like it don't sound like you're normal
Christmas that I'm used
to yeah is it me is it me attic or is it
a little low maybe it sounds low yeah it
sounds low it just sounds low that's all
it is we got to make we got to make sure
you know his levels is good got the best
that the most dangerous stars of the
game yeah
quick question
is that better for you
I think we're gonna have to send you a
whole the line shirt man so here's all
right let's let's talk about this hold
the line thing let's go because
apparently nobody understands how
business Works in a 17 000 sub YouTube
channel can not only create an
incredible meme but also monetize the
meme properly like a business explain
that to me okay how you guys have 700
live viewers on a 17K sub Channel I have
48 000 subs and you guys get more
viewers are the same as me sometimes so
explain that to me in a live sense
number one number two you make a funny
meme you make a joke it comes out
hilarious people like it and what do you
do instead of leaving it alone you make
a t-shirt
what's wrong with that how is that a
problem
that's marketed it's marketing it just
goes to show that nobody takes this
stuff seriously and if they did maybe
they would not be sitting there with
their stagnant channels not making any
sort of monetary compensation I've
sponsored I'm sponsored by Star Ford
systems am I am I selling out now
I mean all your hard work and ground
means nothing now you just take it
if I go and I meet
King as the organ I take pictures with
them are they paying me um
get into it we're gonna get it no I feel
you I feel you bro how dumb this sounds
like I guarantee you I know exactly what
happened Cog and and it's so hilarious
how people are taking a photo and then
trying to dissect the photographs it's
like somebody takes pictures
with people that they almost again
I love what I love what Alex said like
he really tries
look listen there's a whole like you
guys you guys seen my streams right now
like I'm really trying I'm like I'm like
at a one round no I appreciate it I know
you're going extra hard on the Lord's
Day
what's funny I told I told Alex
I was like wait till Carl talks then Joy
yeah that's good let them cook let them
cook listen you want to talk about hard
let's talk about your bicep bro you
ain't had to hit me with the beefy
though why you have to hit me with the
beefy bro yeah
out of here now
introducing and outro going that's what
that dude's gonna draw a picture
oh man it's over it's over he got beef
FiOS and beefy thoughts
I got a um shirt that I want to do and
it's gonna be hilarious but I gotta get
his approval now get approved but it's
gonna be hilarious Man
David body pillow with both sides
I see Alexander today
so we got the uh like like for real
though like it's it's honestly
ridiculous that you can't go if you guys
aren't like you guys are focused more on
Xbox and than really anything else
really so you guys enjoy a brand that's
not a big deal it's not a problem you
guys meet the people who run the brand
okay great whatever so then why is it a
problem when you guys do it but it's not
a problem when Colin Moriarty has Shuhei
Yoshida at his house for the record
piece of love I just like you said for
the record but no no real talk real talk
it's I'm glad he said that I'm glad no
Alex I'm glad you said that I'm glad you
said no beef no beef no cheese but
here's the thing let me go let me go
because here's the thing the the there's
the latest constellation I just did with
Colin Jean Park and myself about this
same subject and Gene is the home we
love it you love it too so the thing is
this came up and I basically expounded
even further that the topic was moral
color let me just go because this is
going to lead into where I'm going so
look I don't know you know the beefiest
Lord should all be Lord can I whatever
and
so look you know shout out to uh Mr
Maddie plays y'all defining Duke
obviously you know let me just I have to
talk about it because the Lord the Dukes
should know what's going on everybody at
Duke land know what's going on but the
Lords don't so the timeline is as
follows apparently there was a
constellation with Jeffy Maddie Colin
and David I guess they were talking
about why Xbox right why do people have
an Infinity for Xbox during that
conversation
out of pocket oh the beefy this is out
of pot y'all see Alex come here and do
this look what y'all doing look at y'all
doing anyway so bull so you know they
talk about that and then object of you
know whether or not I guess my name came
up and it's subject about like what why
does the Lords or why do need to
associate or take pictures we feel maybe
it you know devalues your brand that
kind of energy so Maddie board I didn't
know I know this went down so Maddie
brought into my attention and I didn't
watch the clip to be honest when I
responded on Duke so basically I said
what I had to say there and basically
defending the fact that look everything
I worked for I've grinded I put in the
work this whole thing about iron Lords
podcast is the celebration when I call
you Lord Alex it's a celebration of what
you do in the space we celebrate and
also let's be real a lot of a lot of
Gamers don't know how the game industry
work including myself then sometimes I
didn't know so who better not to get it
from the source right the people that's
out there and for me I didn't think I
was going to be in the games industry so
I'm celebrating these creatives if I
take a picture which if I see I'm taking
a picture with you you know what I'm
saying but you know I pull all my die
out
so exactly so that's what this is this
platform was built on celebrating now to
your point when constellation came out I
happened to be on it that episode and
that's when I went further the subject
was moral compass and is it possible
that you could legitimately have a
friend is it possible that you could
take a picture with somebody and your
bias is not affected you could still go
in on them if they do something that you
don't like numerous times behind the
scenes I've done this and to people's
face so that was the thing and we we
said that Colin was fantastic on this
episode Colin told about all he
literally pulled out some stuff trust me
y'all watch this episode this episode at
Gene Park is a g like literally broke it
down and it comes down to the individual
and how they act and it's up to the
listener to say okay you know what not
the way he moved he gonna call it how he
gonna call it and that was it it was it
was a beautiful thing so salute to
jaffee you know as far as like look it
ain't no beef he taught we him talk
behind the scene we may potentially do
something behind the scene but I'm glad
shout out to you shout out to everyone
the
whole thing is fine I think if you are
up front with your audience and you are
direct with them and saying Hey look
I've met this person hears us together
you know whatever or they flew me out
here's why like what's going on because
of course there's going to be times when
you're like I got this code like you
have to disclose absolutely when you are
sponsored in a video absolutely
absolutely FTC guidelines
two points of mentioned for the for the
CSI investigation that's going on for
the record like the addicts I paid for
the left Aaron just happened I went to
go meet content creators we have a
dinner I mean breakfast and Aaron just
comes through so I'm not gonna be uh and
be like he's like yo can I let's take a
picture together of course all right
cool no problem you're throwing up he
thought everybody thought about doing
wakanda I think I was like whatever so
that's literally what that is so again a
lot of this is a reflection of the
people some some of the people you know
what I mean that feel away because it
ain't situation I can't get mad if a
certain base you know feels away about
something I know who I am as a person so
that's pretty much what it is it is what
is no beef shout out to everybody my day
ones y'all was variety it was like [__]
in the world say the word and I'm like
nah it's no beef we're moving in love
but that's pretty much the blood of it
and like I said hopefully you know maybe
something to come out of us as a
learning experience for being Japanese
the one thing I think Xbox has done
really well
um is is um organic they've been able to
actually do something with content
creators and provide that sense now as a
content creator it's your responsibility
to then divulge and say hey look I am I
have been in communication with Xbox
they're telling me this or telling me
that or they sponsored me here they sent
me there that is your responsibility as
a content creator if you're not doing
that that's that's on you that's no
problem facts if but the thing is what
Xbox has done with content creators
working with them giving them
information providing them some sort of
like way of having access to those
higher level Executives things like that
that's always a good thing because then
you can say Hey look this is information
that I have I've been able to speak to
them about these concerns that I was
having or the community was having and
then we brought them to this table here
you go that's just that is wanting to
have a better brand that you like and
backed up I wish Sony would do that as
well
they stopped it yeah they used to yeah
however
years of evidence of my channel that
Sony fans are a little bit unhinged
sometimes and that may be the reason why
they don't want to do it
and they don't want to do it it's just
the fact that they're not in a position
to need them
well I mean it also let's be honest it
you know from I guess you had a leader
perspective it's always it always
behooves the third place dude to be like
yo we got to get out there they gotta
grind yeah
here's my rebuttal to that let's go does
Coca-Cola still Market their product
as aggressively as when they had to Coke
inside the uh
Coca-Cola Coca-Cola still has a fan this
is a food analogy I'm gonna get roasted
on yeah
but if you look at in terms of marketing
from what Coca-Cola does if they they
clearly said if we stop marketing people
will forget about it so yeah if you're
number one you should still Market oh
absolutely absolutely never take your
base for granted I agree I agree that's
pretty much it but um yeah shout out to
uh Maddie shout out to everybody that
was involved shout out to Jeff shout out
to everybody shout out to community um
as far as me also shout out to um Taco
Travis shout out Dawn's last word was
lit we did we had uh Rick Hackus on talk
about the whole lot yeah Rick was in his
bag it was absolutely amazing that was
the one of the only times that I
fanboyed out yeah
he was messing with us from way back
before yeah hey Rick crackers here yeah
no doubt salute salute so I've been
doing that and um yeah other than that
finish Diablo did the uh main campaign
finish Diablo yeah
cause I'm sick and tired of you oh what
happened
today's the day that the fraud alert
gonna be used a lot
I'm gonna tell you this man is the
hardest worker I don't know do you got a
clone
because yo I don't I don't I work right
but when I game I sit down and I get my
game on
I'm always in the middle of all these
games yeah what's going on this [__] is
choosing to to to play games over sleep
so okay so yeah sometimes let's play one
game at a time yeah sometimes sometimes
it'd be you you get that extra long
blade session you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah but I don't know how you did
that but I put in at least two to three
hours a day on Diablo yeah
I'm still Level I just what level 39.
but I'm one of those people that want to
go to Every Little stop story yeah
you're never gonna be there that's a
waste of time because honestly like
Diablo I have a lot of problems with
that game right away I think it's I
don't think it's as good as people say
it is and I think who just played Diablo
for their first time or three was their
first one it's honestly a horrible
action World Thing game
it's honestly one of the worst that I've
ever played the Lilith issues are an
incredible busy signal that just make
you do nothing for nothing because your
stats should have been like that from
the first place for the Statue so you're
already de-leveled when you get there
scaling for enemies is absolutely
garbage I slipped again
because you know you don't get powerful
as you level you actually get weaker as
you level
um the entire renowned system should
just be account wide instead of actually
character wide because they're doing
some things here and there but Renown is
just busy work for busy work you should
have had those points from the beginning
yeah like that should have been there
from the start there's no reason to go
and fish for points you should have had
since you actually started the actual
going hey damn
like no like so the immobilization and
Unstoppable is is ridiculous there's no
way to understand Buffs or debuffs on
your character there's no limit on them
uh the mount is broken on PC and
keyboard and mouse because you have to
have your mouse cursor farther away from
your Mount when you're writing in order
to go faster or else you do an RP walk
when you're slower uh skeleton barricade
stop you so you have to Dismount then
kill the skeletons then remount six
seconds later so you're gonna cool down
yeah you want to go down I don't know
it's so dumb like a lot of these things
don't make like nightmare dungeons are
boring the sigils you ain't like nothing
he's like destroying my game okay here's
here's hell tied you ready whoa I'm on
tier three now what do I gotta do I
gotta Farm hell Tides every hour until I
get good enough gear then beat the
Capstone which is a joke oh I'm on tier
four again guess what I gotta do again
boys more Health ties
again it's just same thing over and over
I have less skills that I did in Diablo
3 because they took the skills away yeah
yeah I did notice and then they put them
in the affixes of the legendaries
instead so you can't even do a proper
build until you get the right affix of
the legendary it's it makes you just you
know just don't play oh man
this is the Path of Exile what a good
video game
I do like I do like Path of Exile though
I do like that so yeah I enjoyed my
experience at all I just don't know how
I'm just at a loss
when do you get time to either run I
don't know you have to be on something
to give you this is it focused because
everybody's doing the focus
GG in there but um so look at the end of
the day sponsors do you guys
you don't even bother yourself how much
money does this guy say have one
real but see Alex you have to get focus
on my regular drinks and it allows me to
focus a little bit more I mean this
stuff is really and it doesn't give you
any Jitters this is ridiculous what's
your discount color plugger yeah Lord
Advance GG you know make sure you go get
that code iron off for that 10 off but
uh real quick
on that one iron Lord L O R D is in the
description Alex your bike is popping
for some weird reason is
bro I love you bro appreciate the
content you know what I'm saying I love
that you know obviously keep it real
even you even went in or not so it's no
you know yeah but you see something like
you talk about it and I really
appreciate you representing people
because you come from that grind you
come from putting in the work week after
week day after day we've seen your
progression we're super proud of you bro
what you're doing right now is insane so
you guys do brother for sure just just
lay off dirt man
no he's gonna get cooked like everybody
else oh
anyway I do things to get on his show
and I'll be disappointed on Thursday I
was like nah man I popped off yesterday
anyway
when we get on Alex
Alex
listen like back to pillow oh man
first of all this feels like a
slaughterhouse I walked into because
there's so much beef in here right wow
and having oh no it's Alex here Alex
first of all big fan love what you do
there brother uh but you just made me
really self-conscious first of all I'm
speaking on a Blue Yeti
number two I'm loving Diablo well here
you are speaking out against it so um
I wanted to hear your justification why
Blue Yeti isn't isn't sufficient enough
to use a Blue Yeti
so it is it is this do you would you
agree that it is a competent mic but
when you start taking stuff more
seriously you should upgrade from it no
it's not a confident mic
for 100 bucks you can just get a road a
road pod mic at the same price and have
better audio than that I feel you I feel
you I feel it I just feel like that's
what I'm talking about
when it comes to constructive criticism
but you know what I think it is too I
think Alex is like like really really
tone on like when it comes to sound like
it seems like that's his biggest like
pet peeve too like as long as I can hear
you fluently and I don't feel like like
I'm mistaking your words for anything
that's fine for me like nah I'm gonna
tell you this
if you can give constructive criticism
in that way and he did it and dealer did
it too and it's just yo you can step up
this aspect into the change how you are
perceived I love constructive criticism
because it works because so when Dirk
you know gets the the the check in in
the month he probably looks at the other
mic and let me let me upgrade it let me
change it let me see if it works and
then maybe he might use some of the
stuff uh that Alex was talking about to
change some of his program maybe so I
see the chat like oh your mic is popping
it's Zoom oh I don't blame Zoom don't
play Zoom listen
is Mike incompatible with Zoo he need a
Blue Yeti
real quick
[Laughter]
yo [__] man what's been going on with
you brother we gotta see falls in the
realm too so it's late yeah we got
everybody up in here oh man I gotta go
guys bye all right brother Alex
come on what's up brother hey nothing
much uh spotted uh carrier pigeon showed
up with the invite so I had to drop on
in here thank you very much
shelf behind your head it's dope thank
you thank you very much nowhere's near
your shelves no no no no no no no no
said Alex your mic sounds like Rice
Krispies snap crackles
that was the irony of the situation
since you can't talk about anyone's
audio who sounded like that
Derek Sabaton dirt sabotage
Dirks ain't a shooter no doubt no doubt
and of course the legend my homie Gay's
talk live the fods what's going on how
we do it what is going on everybody it's
it's good to be here is my mic popping
I like the Glorious Glory
it's perfect yeah
yo
so you know he's running away
come on I really I really want you to
like to do a late night talk so yeah
thank you so much because yo it reminds
me of Frankie Crocker if you got that
that Frankie Crocker hell listen I used
to sit there with my grandmoms all the
time but that voice is is just certain
voice like Don Cornelius like yeah very
iconic boy yes very iconic voice you got
a voice that's made that's just
ridiculous baby let's go let's go I
appreciate that you know at one time I
hated my voice literally I did not like
it and then when I started podcasting
you know I started getting compliments
and I'm like what okay yeah all right
you know let's go with it yeah so it's
it's been a lot of fun man I'm just glad
to be back here on the iron Lords
podcast let's let me just say you guys
have grown exponentially and not
surprising at all I I knew this the
first day I saw you guys do your thing I
kept hitting Cog up and telling him you
guys are gonna go very far because you
guys got an IT Factor like no other it's
that camaraderie that friendship you
guys just coming together every Sunday
and doing your thing is just nothing
more than just awesome I love what you
do for the community you guys make
everybody feel good out there myself
included I've been going through some
tough times not going to bore you with
that but but you guys have really lifted
Spirits uh my spirits up every Sunday I
appreciate you guys appreciation
for doing what you guys do that's a lot
you've been one of our day ones you've
seen the vision from the beginning yes
and always would encourage me and when
we were low you know like bro I'll do it
anyway yeah what's up
I was here for your uh your your big um
what was it 200th episode or whatever
I was trying I was trying to get on
um but I was really sick and I just have
to tell people that I I came down with
covid that weekend I didn't know that
wow so so uh you you were the one that
ended up telling me hey maybe it's
covered related go get tested I got
tested sure enough yeah I was hurting
bad but uh I tried to make it for that
episode I tried this I appreciate you
pulled up I just let people know if they
saw me on this you know the stream it's
not that I didn't want to talk trust me
Fonz wanted to talk to the iron Lords
because I I I've always loved what you
guys do here so I appreciate you but
that's a little good day see y'all here
pong is always loved holding this down
the whole bit so look we're gonna get
into a little show I appreciate
everything and appreciate everybody that
pulled up to show support for the whole
other situations that was going on I got
a thousand people watching we gotta yeah
we say even the spotted uh what is it
the spotted lightning bug whatever that
bug was no we're gonna save it
see him I'm gonna kill him when I see
him putting hands on him pause but um
please let's let's say put that like
it's okay King are we lock in any of our
special guests behind the likes today or
or I don't know what I would do is if we
can get a thousand likes today I'll
stream some more Final Fantasy for y'all
can we hear you this time no you can't
why because the PlayStation doesn't
allow me to talk
isn't that ironic PlayStation doesn't
want to hear me speak oh anyway moving
off from you or you mention this
um real quick or I had to go to get the
super chess yeah yeah we got a whole
bunch of people
goodness for this only yes salute the
YouTube for putting the what is it
took long enough but we got it done yeah
we got the new only fan section over
there
all right so we got a uh we got a member
chat for 32 months from Gerald Mack
shout out to the graveyards in the
building we outside hashtag we them boys
all the hell the uh IOP salute the
Lord's the end near uh hashtag uh xwo
yeah yeah uh you know put it put in the
chat got a member for 36 months Cedric H
put in the put the logo in the chat guys
Nelson W gaming thank you uh thank you
all for everything you do y'all do F the
haters it's just a fun it's just a pick
it shouldn't be an attack on Cog uh
Integrity uh definitely agreement say
something
where was the um vitriol when we were
showing pictures when we was all suited
up with Todd how would you want to smoke
for that they're like no no you do you
y'all are y'all upset cause he was
eating
somebody was hungry and saw them eating
food because we took better pictures
doing nothing but y'all saw some food
and got out of bounds
I didn't think I didn't listen to me I
wasn't going to talk about it I wasn't
explaining that shout out to greedy was
like yo I didn't pay for anything and
the funny is I paid for that that was
the funny part of the whole situation
there's more plates Than People you guys
don't understand
complete CSI investigations on July 4th
I was like I made it I'm lit I'm lit bro
anyway
so we gotta find those picture from
Robert kellets happy Sunday Lords I know
you've got beefy
you got beefy on K and then on Deck to
discuss Final Fantasy 16 sales issues
but what other news you got to report in
general quite is is General any
personality is coming through King I
don't know we got to see it once we get
a thousand likes oh a thousand likes we
might see he might show up for the Final
Fantasy
we'll see you know we got a little bit
before that final fantastic hit that
like button if you guys want to see
absolutely Gerald Mack shout out to the
uh shout out to the at beefy lore's roof
feathers out there like a boss all hell
the ILP salute the Lords two dollar
subscribe for Robert Kelly got Jedi
Survivor and it works great at 30 frames
per second
um you're not playing the game man
you're playing a PowerPoint we got a
member wow a member chat for three
months uh from Astro parenting the Mets
have uh may have lost but IOP Stadium oh
absolutely
I have a lord beefy will eat breakfast
whoever he wants to type it type of day
does the D
real quick before you uh I want to break
protocol shout out to the legend Paris
Lily in the chat he said cog's one of
the most genuine people in the street
this land is nice and I appreciate you
but thank you for that and again you
know I'm saying as as black men I love
that we don't have to pull each other
down right we could be still doing our
things and forget race no matter who we
are as content creators like we don't
have to pull each other down we can lift
each other up and that's the beauty of
this thing so salute to you on that I
meant a lot but we gotta find out some
stuff from Nintendo John the otaku every
time Cox said no shot on the funny dude
bodies popped up all over the town uh uh
country ain't no evidence but they had a
note that said beefy next to each spot
[Laughter]
we gotta really go with this beefy thing
I think we need a beefy meme graphic God
yo they really chat talk about Cognito
I'm done
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
keep it moving let's go get the Super
Chat sir do your job do you do your job
sir
five dollars for Robert Kelly even
though you that uh you three Maddie and
Jazz aren't huge on Final Fantasy 16.
it's currently my game of the year
Amazing Story great presentation and the
combat is awesome 720p is not yeah I
respectfully uh disagree with your
opinion I decline that offer actually I
don't respectfully do it I'm generally
attacking your opinion but it is what it
is
from My Name Is Mud okay
A little extra to go with that Microsoft
check I appreciate that man yeah
whatever we get the micro whatever
whenever we get that microwave put that
five with it I see you heavily funded
too I see you had to drop top with the
oh fuzz was outside yo how much they
paid you this one bro man you know what
we ain't gonna disclose that but I'll
just say you know some people came at me
because of the type of car it was and
everything I'm like well while you're
cranking your window down I'm over here
the touch of a button opening up my
panoramic sunroof
shout out to every content creator crazy
oh picking up what I dropped right in
the car thing yeah
and I was like oh my goddess right and
you know come out and Colt did it go
into the car then I see Hans dude
everybody in the contract everybody
shout out to Crazy Lou he did it in the
house like yo I got to fix this part
over here
communities has so much fun with this
super chat from internal uh should I hey
oh Sonata I wasn't even gonna try it
because the king how much is Microsoft
paying you to keep yourself offline uh
to play fortnite we had some great
battles and some combat talks I still
want my cut because we was playing I
thought we agreed that you was going to
pay that man what happened well I did
slide him as pulse
um some uh slid with some beefy stuff
what you were sliding content skins
[Laughter]
I don't know man you're gonna you your
name is Ben butcher I already know I'm
here what's good Lord thank you
bless hundred percent and beefy beefy
arm uh five dollar speed trap from
Hollywood Rose IOP Sunday have a great
show Bros King wash these big mouth
dudes up there calling my Sega bro BK
got your back jealousy is something else
hashtag ponies is going to Pony who that
way who is that a whole Hollywood what
does Hollywood Hollywood I'm surprised
we not lizard people
talk to him okay let's go we got a
member chat from Dragonheart yo we've
been a member for 24 months two years
King I left you a birthday gift in
Fortnight my brother I love you all keep
up the Fantastic work what are you mean
in the future call
me courtesy of the hashtag peace love
life movement crew why ain't nobody ever
gifted me so well because you don't play
fortnite like that
um
I'm good
we got we got a six Super Chat from
Unforgiven Lords get that breakfast
sponsor salt in the womb all right got a
two dollars for uh hard to find pause on
going hard on the mic call
uh we we did already get the let's play
with each other we don't need to get
that again move on we got two dollars
from zip Davis Hi Lords can I get an
amen and an extra beefy
authenticity of the Lords is unmatched
don't let them come at the king and Miss
final switch are from Ultra msv mad
respect to the Grind every time I get in
to tune in y'all always kill it also we
need Lord beefy shirts no we don't I
really think we do and I'm graphic God
Hollywood rules the only podcast that
I'm a patreon member so here's more well
fun the best Xbox shelling and beefy pod
period you guys are always approachable
and professional always ignore the
haters hashtag Hold the Line ah
appreciate it I gotta tell y'all this I
did not forget about
um the console giveaway didn't forget
about that that's gonna be uh for
patreon and stuff like that and um r r
is coming back next week we already got
the overlay that if you would uh Ty and
myself uh doing it and that'll be on
patreon we're going to do a year uh
encapsulation on so far of the movies
and what we've been watching so check
that out no doubt continue got it uh
gotta find out from Danny passion
official people don't understand that
hard work pays off crazy that people
need to explain this let's go I'm an X
bot plus don't forget my cut from the
bad
salute daily super trap for the angry
therapist MD in New Jersey it's death on
site with that thing okay yeah he's
talking about that bug oh this bug
uh two dollars which icon artistic Alex
is hella funny language yeah
and put um put some put some logos in
the chat for hustle motivate and DC
walks they just join the round
definitely put a put some Logans in the
chat man absolutely subscribe from GSD
getting stuff done the stream cross
again the streams cross again oh you
know super trap from tsws gaming Cog
knows the beef and Onyx it's not easy
out there out here salute oh I just
jumped me I got you I got you Lucius
Augustus five dollar Super Chat I find
it funny that people get to question why
we like Xbox you never questioned why
Nintendo or Sony fans enjoy those Brands
just seems hypocritical okay
well we love the ugly girl it's the
double stand being applied to people who
like Xbox that's the problem it comes
off as hating and joffy was definitely
hating that's all love brother we moving
in love
Cog and Alex on the same show beefy boys
I just want to hear fonze you've been
naughty phones
no
you know what I like the fox say no
Alex is
the reason he the reason he ain't saying
that he's not having people cut that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I I see
what kind of uh you know certain people
you have in your chat sometimes yeah you
know I see the ones that have an
affinity towards uh SOB yes yes yes yes
yes absolutely he was just like no how
do you shut that right there continue
uh we gotta find us our two dollars from
Delta 169 shout out to the iron Lords
and King Hold the Line find us who tried
from bean dip dip slip everybody the
haters y'all put on the best content
every week but uh best Xbox podcast so
far and Kings happy be late uh late
birthday
happy belated name birth related name
Dave now why can't you guys just speak
English
happy belated boys yeah he said it
that's what
he's been a member for 14 months a
little over a year happy Sunday Lords
this is one beefy uh swirl of a podcast
I know what you're doing I know what
you're doing I know what you're doing we
got the baby going forward we got a
member trap from Lloyd Metro he's been a
member for 21 months almost two years
this is the best gaming Sunday podcast
always open-minded keep up the good work
tears of the Kingdom has gave me the
year of course much respect gentle could
you talk about nuts and bolts too oh man
salute
two dollar subscribe for Lord Metro uh
digiornos DiGiorno's pizza cogs beef
limited edition oh my god
let's not front front we all signed that
membership form there was an extra plate
proof that that it was called coach's
wife who took the pick nah yeah I
couldn't remember if it was Colt's wife
or it was a wife yeah salute who was
there who was there who also paid for
his half on the table so salute to them
brother Cognito the side piece to joist
it oh no we're not doing that you're not
doing that
there we go it's exactly why you're not
clippings
he sent you off
continue
uh it just dropped me again oh I got you
um young dreads that's the artist he
said laugh a lot it's young dreads attic
LOL that's when you just say his name
right too loud Super Chat I'm still
gonna butcher it it's fine though no I
know we got Diogo Diego padrao and uh I
think I don't know what currency is but
it's twenty dollars in it we need that
fraud alert King was playing Final
Fantasy 16 with them easy trinkets on
and don't come go come with the I have
too many games to play after you jump
right night or a fortnight oh no well
listen I'm gonna tell you this and and
most of the time I put everything on
easy why because I don't have the time
in my day like you do
be the guy into submission mode I don't
care who are you yourself too it's just
it's just not an achievement of anything
games are supposed to be fun that's
something that you want to throw your
control
the only time that I would disagree with
that is if you go on Twitter and like
brag that you beat hard games and stuff
like but you don't do that you don't do
that like like if I was going out there
playing games on easy mode they could
call me a fraud but you don't come out
there and you know like to play those
hard games you know that's that's why I
kind of had a point of contention with
uh oh no it's Alex earlier when he was
talking about Diablo four let's go and
he was talking about how you know the
game is not good blah blah blah blah
blah I don't want to hear that Alex if
the game is fun to me it's fun yeah it
doesn't matter your opinion on this game
is not as good as that game was or it's
not as good as this you know at the end
of the day if people are having fun with
a game you can't wrong them I mean
they're right
so yeah it's all subjective brother
everybody I love Alex but yeah that kind
of irks me when people talk about you
know you can't like that game because
it's not as good as this was or is not
as good as that you know it's like dude
it's a fun game because currently right
now it's probably my game of the year
yeah
it's my game of the year as well but
isn't that how we open up
um the conversation to get to game of
the year right by knocking down points
on let's say whatever they put up and
you say well you know compared to this
or to that if it's in the same genre I
don't care what they put out 10 years
ago
and if the game is
game is then it's fun
it's it I mean look I I know some people
want to
put themselves on a higher pedestal
sometimes and talk as if they they know
better than you with this gaming stuff
but at the end of the day like if it's
fun to you that's all but that's what it
matters
yeah I get permission from everyone
no you're you're five you're fine put
some logos in the chat man Eternal
Sanai whatever uh appreciate for joining
the round man put the logos in the chat
welcome the new member to the chat uh
thank you uh Super Chat from the Gina uh
okay ray P Bobby Kendrick getting that
bag this week there was nothing stopping
him from getting that back he was always
gonna get that back all right all right
we all done all right so now we are
going to train
into uh actually I messed up last week
because I was
um last week poll yeah because I didn't
do it
so last week was not in
and it was six hour podcast and I forgot
so the poll that you were supposed to
get we'll be coming back at the end of
the show because it's actually still
relevant so stay tuned for that we do
have some patreon questions that I do
have to take care of
um shout out to sack shop controversial
question y'all got phones right anyone
playing the Final Fantasy VII ever
crisis beta it's currently on Android
the Xbox of the mobile space don't at me
I know this is a hundred percent I
gotcha game but man this thing is pretty
good any of you mobile heathens check
this out yet
soon let's start with let's actually
start with the guess I'm curious let's
stop it Paul are you planning to be a
mobile Heathen Pong Song no sir pcmr
recently I'm not moving to Mobile so
we're good we're good no I do put I I
will play games on the phone from time
to time it's just not something I go out
of my way to do right most of the time
it's to stream or whatever else if I
don't pick up I was doing a lot of
octopath traveler uh back in the day on
mobile perfect game for that that so I
have dabbled there uh but no I won't go
out of my way to try one okay uh Mr
Fonzarelli sir no I um I I don't even
dabble with phone games I think it's uh
just a waste of my time especially if
I'm out somewhere I'm not gonna whip out
my phone and start playing a game or
whatever it's just it's not that serious
you know especially with most of the
games that are out there the controls on
the phones just yeah yeah and I'm not
putting like a quiche in my pocket or
anything so what's funny is the majority
of the people that that mobile market is
aiming for isn't us like I have younger
people in my family that exclusively
play on their phones because they they
grew up playing on those weird touch
screen controls different generation for
sure
King your lord mobile used to be gears
pop he was oh he is lawful oh what's
that that's Candy Crush what we doing no
no this is Royal match Royal Mallory so
tell us what's going on yeah this so so
Royal match um and I'm not sponsored by
Royal match but Royal match if you want
to sponsor
um
what I like about Royal match is it
doesn't have any ads that pop up and you
know have you you know play because a
lot of mobile games when you're playing
them a bunch of ads pop up so I kept
seeing the advertisement for it all the
time all the time all the time and then
I realized let me try it because I was
playing mobile games and ads just
popping up that was the biggest problem
to me because they're always Shilling
you something this game doesn't do that
um it doesn't require you to buy
anything and it's um I like puzzlers I
like keeping my brain active throughout
the day so anytime I'm like standing
online is it quick and easy distraction
I used to play Gears pop a lot I
remember everybody look at my um my game
attack you'll see a lot of hours inside
gears Pop I thought it was a crazy good
game until they discontinued it I don't
know what Microsoft was thinking about
but um yeah I'm part of the Heathen team
when certain Games come out so I
probably would try the Final Fantasy if
it doesn't have a ton of pop-ups and ads
that come through
yeah it does look good and my phone is
hella powerful so it's way more powerful
than my Turbo Graphics back in the day
my PlayStation yeah it's crazy why not a
game on something that was uh it is way
more more powerful than the machines
that I was having so much joy with back
in the day no doubt I think for me yeah
I'm kind of on the phones but I'm not
never probably gonna be a mobile guy
however there is one game pong that is
tempting me well as as the MCU guy that
that Marvel's yeah it's try and I'm
trying to stay awake because
it was very dangerous for me I had to
had to make up situations I had a fake
son to get some bills off my account bro
it was it was bad it was bad I I have a
very addictive personality with stuff
like that but I love something so yeah
so I I did play a game it wasn't it was
on mobile but it was a Facebook game it
was called like Marvel Alliance or
something like that and uh you would
have to like buy it was a turn-based
game and you would have to like I I was
obsessed with that game right I think I
got like every hero every season I got
so much they had to send me a check for
like 500 when they closed the game down
oh yeah wow that's wow late snap for
three weeks it was actually really good
it was really good
I had to delete it yeah right yeah yeah
I played Snake on my old Nokia back in
the day a little bit remember that they
came with your Nokia yeah it was just
there yeah you know salute so no ads all
right next paycheckers we do have uh two
more snail killer how should we rate
Final Fantasy XV should we rate it as a
non-final fantasy game or does sequels
affect the way we rate games addict this
is all you to set it off first
um how should we rank it he said how
should we rate it he said because should
you rate it as a non-final fantasy game
or the fact that there's a final fantasy
sequels effect the way or the fact that
sequels affect the way we rate games
because there were other final fantasies
beloved I mean you could do both you
could write it as a as a Final Fantasy
game it's just really really bad or you
could rate as an on Final Fantasy game
and it's a a quality Final Fantasy game
uh a quality game it's just not a good
Final Fantasy game like if you took the
Final Fantasy at this and that terrible
blue blooster whatever to the title
instead you it's gonna be a lot better
because you don't have that Final
Fantasy expectation with just having the
name Final Fantasy uh you know I
honestly think this should have been a
spin-off like Final Fantasy like you
know that that god-awful game that no
one liked uh Final Fantasy Origins
if they would have made this origin this
would because when I play 16 it just
screams high quality spin often
um I think it's in between like Spirits
within and Advent Children that's where
it should be because it's mostly movie
honestly um
at that point they should have just made
it
look I'm enjoying the story if I wasn't
enjoying the story of the of the game I
would not like this game at all and I
just wouldn't because even the combat
itself is not very compelling so far
yeah
um I don't have everything unlocked but
I have you know several things unlocked
and it's still not clicking with me it's
it's it's basically a button Masher the
the band the time that I'm enjoying the
game the most is like you said is when
the cutscenes are playing yeah but then
that story is unraveling it's it's the
movie right at that point and it doesn't
feel like a Final Fantasy game per se it
just doesn't
a good movie
Advent Children and um has everyone here
seen I've been chosen yeah um I see the
bits of pieces of it but yeah
um they didn't really uh hit that Mark
but they look cool do you think you need
to watch having children Square fell in
love with trying to produce a movie
that's Interactive
that's why we're getting these their
final fantasies like no I I think I
think this comes down to Yoshi P I think
the the man you know that was behind
really pulling up for Fantasy uh Final
Fantasy 14 out of the Grave pretty much
right um and doing big things for them a
lot of people who've played a lot of
Final Fantasy 14 tell me that this game
um especially when it comes to the heavy
cinematics is a lot like the DLC they
would get for that game right um so I
think this has a lot to do with him and
pedigree especially uh his you know
being with you know
um he was he made uh he helped make one
of the Devil May cries and stuff like
that back in the day I I think the
combat they they're trying to do
something that's a little too different
out of the realm of Final Fantasy in my
opinion yeah I think that's where they
kind of slip up I mean don't get me
wrong it's it's a good game it's not
terrible by any means but it's just not
feeling like Final Fantasy
like an amazing game like this is like
Towers over there just service but I
would consider them in the same vein
yeah I think I I I think though that
it's it's just like Final Fantasy uh
7 remake is is a better example of the
gameplay I would have liked them to just
continue with that quasi you know turn
based yeah right traditional action but
but there's that slo-mo that happens and
stuff like there were some cool things
in that combat that I really enjoyed but
here in Final Fantasy it's basically
like a wannabe Devil May Cry Bayonetta
but it never really hits those strides
in Combos and stuff or it doesn't feel
like it does so far to me I don't know
it's just my opinion people it is it's a
polarizing subject right A lot of people
feel different way upon I think it's a
valid opinion to be honest to Final
Fantasy 16 from the outside looking in
sure I can I can give you my outside as
somebody who has played plenty of Final
Fantasy but hasn't touched this one yet
um you know I think that they're trying
to do something different which is fine
but I do think that you can move too far
away from what got you here
um and I think that that like Fonz just
said that kind of Towing the line
between May Cry in Final Fantasy but
removing you know RPG aspects which oh
yes the Mainstay in the franchise that's
where I think they really went sideways
it's fine if you want to introduce new
combat mechanics they've been doing that
for a while in final fantasies that's
you know that's something that they've
been evolving for a long time
um and it's cool I think it's great it
can it can reinvigorate a fan base
sometimes too to try something new it
can also turn some people off obviously
there's a whole group that want turn
base back right completely which I
understand I'm a third base fan but I I
think that this time that they did they
went too far in the direction of a
action narrative Sony type game right
that third person type game and it
didn't stick enough to the Final Fantasy
side I like Lord addicts you know like
addicts uh idea that this could have
definitely been a spin-off game had they
promoted it that way instead of a
Mainline Final Fantasy I think that's
where you can go try and experiment a
little bit more is if you don't make it
that Mainline game I I think that
alienates less of the fan base that way
but I think that's where a little bit of
the problem is right now
I think um I think my position is kind
of like the way each of them have come
out it's always been in the like they've
always been separate things I always
feel like the games obviously do not
link to each other so to the question
should we how should we rate it I've
always read it on its own individual
Merit but I understand the sentiment
that so people who are upset that it's
going away from quote-unquote its core
roots of jrpg and traditional gameplay
and as a person that played it my issue
um was the combat like I do miss a
little bit of the turn-based stage even
with Final Fantasy 7 remake the fact
that they had the switching between the
slow motion between the cells it still
kind of felt a little turn-basy where
this is straight action for some people
it's gonna rub them wrong I do like the
story I do like the dark nature of it
but um I understand why people are
conflicted so yeah we will talk about
sales and all that stuff later in King's
topic but um yeah it's a good question I
I think it's a good point
um last patreon question dip down games
and made the homies I'm just throwing
this out there
banjo is greater than conquer agree or
disability shut your mouth I disagree I
love you I love you listen I don't even
mean to come off like that on you I love
you and I don't I don't even mean to
jump out there before Cog even passes it
to somebody oh that's a dude that when
conquer came out and what conquer meant
for rare to do that to step outside of
that little kitty box and to make an
adult game that was in the cartoon
nature at that period of time it was so
controversial and you y'all probably
don't even get where the scene started
from Clockwork Orange is probably my
all-time greatest film ever to build
Ultra violence yes
dad that that movie itself just if
you've never seen a movie go see the
movie then look at conquerors again then
you tell me what's greater first of all
and I gotta I got a whatchamacola on my
backpack I got a bird on my back oh baby
that's a banjo sled attitude
you're not messing with a squirrel that
pull out the rats the squirrel had
Yeah Toast y'all want to know what
general King and stuff come from
no you gotta give respect to respecters
do stop putting them in the same boat
there's a reason why one dude is Iconic
and the other dude they say is
irrelevant and they don't care to make a
game about oh man
Nintendo didn't take that corner and put
him in his game okay for that smash for
that smash yeah they they they they they
chose the the real goat they didn't
choose some some small fur ball that no
one cares
that needs help to sell not beef shame
in the beer
[Applause]
all I'm saying is they try to do so many
things and he just didn't click bro
Conker just works
um it works so well we ain't seeing it
down yeah you see Cocker for a minute
what's holding you down what's that mean
what's that means
you're gonna also see the demographic of
age yo dip down go watch Clockwork
Orange you like you know what's funny
King automatically tainted that pool the
moment he said but if we lose we just
see it's because of hey
guess I got a different opinion here
because uh it's not just that I'm
picking conquer and saying it's greater
than banjo I'm picking just about
anything and saying it's better
I think the about the controls in
Banjo-Kazooie were downright horrible I
did I did not like that game maybe it
was the fact that I was already an adult
at the time when that game dropped and
it just didn't really vocal says you
know I was playing
oh no banjo bro
it doesn't even feel good if you go back
and play it you really now uh oh look
what you call it from techy with the dog
you are literally a Tekken character now
officially
yeah just a bunch of hating ass oh
language
you mad cause Coco don't care for banjo
[Laughter]
you went back have you went back and
played banjo yes it's good man
it's not good to you like there's a very
key word yeah you get it I get it I get
it I get it it's an opinion at the end
of the day it's just it's the right
there's so much there's so much it's
losing in the chat used to play out
there talking about it
come on man your man ain't iconic he got
a bird on his back home off the roof
I prefer brute force over banjo
I preferred that game thank God that you
know it's not up to you guys pong we
need you to break this down man what's
going on where you at with this I got
zero horse in this race or either one
dad and buried oh really don't care I
don't care about either one of them
right if I had the Jews if you had to
force me okay if I had to choose then I
go with the humor and I go with [__]
okay
the bee queen that comes out with this
situations
I I'm kind of like bong in this but I I
kind of gotta agree with him it's like
Congo was just wow like it was just what
is going on like what is good this this
thing is out of pocket like it was just
so out of my butt I've never in defense
though I've never really rocked playing
Badger so I can't really go in it's just
that I know I don't grab it none of you
played bands yeah I don't gravitate you
know whenever I see who who
I don't want no parts of that
I just have to ask why is there such a
an affinity for the game for banjo why
is there so much hate we don't bother
you I'm sitting in our little what
there is so many better games that came
out around that era that I don't
understand why people are like clamoring
for a nuke banjo
I will say though but in defense smash
what he was announced it went crazy
that's why I'm asking
questions when you can't understand
something
rather than crap on it but uh I'd rather
ask and addict would be somebody to ask
because he really loves banjo what did
you like about banjo that was so good
I just like the platforming the
atmosphere of the game you know I I like
the fact that they they had a a tune of
mechanics that you've never seen in it
like for instance like when you're
playing through banjo one and you get to
the end because the witch takes your
sister the whole time you're going
through her her castle she's talking to
you she's telling you stuff the whole
time the entire game and you don't think
you think it's just her bantering her
her like clowning on you but when you
get to the end of the game you get into
this like chess board like this game
that she has set up and she's quizzes
throughout the game I like that other
games when they do that they I feel like
they like the fact that she told you
something in the beginning to see if you
remembered at the end
you truly hate it I mean is you putting
it up you putting up a contender against
an icon is it's different levels to this
bro and I feel the exact same way you
putting up the kitchen
you putting on an amateur against an
icon I'm gonna tell you this if if
Microsoft put the poll out in the world
and they had to base it off of the the
answer to that poll there'll be a new
conquer coming before a new banjo I
don't think so yo yo I think so look at
your poll your protest to a bunch
look that is your Army in the chat okay
that's my Army you know what's funny you
be acting like it
you know what's funny he'd be acting
like this pose like five percent
it's oh it's it's almost half it's
almost there goes the excuses
we don't care for your excuses
that will be a better icon for Xbox your
knees
[Laughter]
butter on them that's an interesting
that's an interesting question you asked
her addict what would be better for Xbox
um you know I honestly somebody put up a
a poll on Twitter and they were asking
um what would be a better icon for Xbox
uh
um Raz from Psychonauts or a banjo and I
and I choose Razz all the way I think is
the much better game for a platformer
way better than banjo ever could be
true I mean we're gonna move on that was
the final one I'm sorry to Interruption
thanks dip down no down please dip down
start a lot of drama we got it I love it
gotta get to the first topic yeah also
addict this is you Xbox games oh we're
not even in the first topic yes
you know three o'clock we get to the
first topic okay I mean to be fair that
the topics this week we're gonna have a
little bit of fun but they're nothing
like serious discussions no FTC stuff
yeah exactly yeah
so next week we're talking about the FTC
most likely no doubt so games come man
what's going on Xbox got a presence
there it's your topic that and Tokyo
game show they're going to both this
year that is correct that is true and
apparently Tokyo game shows it's gonna
be like their biggest year they've had
so I don't know if that's like talking
about before the pandemic type of big or
you know it's going to just be a beefy
year for the Tokyo game
[Laughter]
for real
so we need a beefy shark your thoughts
on this what do you think as your topic
addict like what do you think is gonna
happen at Gamescom the presents Xbox or
Bethesda said they're gonna be there
Greenie has put out the Tweet you know
basically stating that um not I didn't
say he didn't say like that temperature
expectations but it was kind of saying
they're looking to show out you know
I love it I have been a huge
person in the community that's been very
vocal about Microsoft really building
their own outlets and their own events
and not necessarily giving all their
stuff to everyone else notice they
weren't at the uh they they wasn't at
the Video Game Awards this year they
wasn't at the you know Jeff Keeley thing
whatever that thing was called the
summer game Fest they were at none of
that stuff and I feel like they could
have easily shown stuff at these events
but they're holding it closer to the
chest is it going to be a huge presence
probably not but we're probably going to
see Game Pass announcements and we're
going to see some form of maybe you know
exclusive indie games or big type of
games that would be more make more sense
in that top part of the world I think
we're going to start seeing more of
these little Events maybe uh a direct to
some degree I don't know if it's going
to be anything big but the fact that
they're there and they're showing their
face in these other parts of the the
world because people need to realize
that just because we
enjoy the Xbox brand where in the states
doesn't mean that's the case everywhere
yeah for the most part
they do have some form of an audience in
other parts of the world but it's mainly
just here you know they they get a lot
of their strongest biggest cells from
this part of the of the world and I
think that's that's the thing they're
doing well you know they've been to
Tokyo game show like two or three years
in a row they're going to Gamescom this
year I I think they're showing like look
we're out in these streets we're we're
showing you what we can do you know we
want to to be better when it comes to
giving better messaging and you know he
came out there he made some uh you know
not necessarily bold statements but some
defining statements and I think that you
know we're gonna see some form of
presence in terms of I don't know if
it's going to be direct or maybe it's
just going to be a couple Tweets in that
day but they're going to be on the show
floor so that's cool but I do think that
we're going to see some form of
announcements at Gamescom I I do think
that no doubt no doubt let's get uh pong
soul in the realm Xboxes they came out
there they said they're going to be you
know at a games called Greenberg with
the Tweet excited to be back this year
to see so many faces familiar and new
our teams have been working hard on our
show floor presence and more this will
be especially yeah looking forward to
sharing even more details soon so Paul
what you're feeling what's your thoughts
about this Xbox and Gamescom yeah and it
wasn't just Greenberg either right kaga
it was Phil Phil came out and said it's
been too many years since my last
Gamescom I'm looking forward to
attending and seeing the community at
the show right
um that means something when the big
man's gonna be in the house that always
means something special to me right
obviously I'm you know right in line
with what attic was just saying
um obviously this is also going to be uh
the last week push before Starfield
launches which is one of your biggest
launches you know again arguably in
decades right as far as a first party
game goes so obviously that's probably
going to be a focus like I said it would
be outside of the norm but I wouldn't
doubt to see Starfield maybe playable on
the floor at Gamescom which would be
huge which would be huge right that yeah
go against Todd normal you know what
Todd likes to do he doesn't want anybody
seeing his game until launch day even
the reviewers right but I think it's
gonna be different for Starfield so I
think this could be a big push there but
I definitely think now that we've got
Greenberg out here talking about this is
an exciting special year for Xbox we
already know that Greenie you guys just
came off the gigantic showcase he came
off of direct for Starfield that blew
people's socks out of the water we know
that what what are you saying is it yeah
I'm double checking to make sure I don't
have my socks on yes
exactly exactly
um so I think that they might have
something special they might have
another thing up their sleeve you know
this goes back to the Giant Bomb
interview with uh Phil and Matt booty as
well uh shout out to Grub and those guys
over there yes um you know they
specifically asked him about another
director what they're kind of we're
gonna do and booty answered well we've
got other things coming up this year
like Gamescom like the Game of the Year
Awards right he specifically mentioned
these shows like attic was saying I'm in
love I I would love the idea that they
have built three uh directs a year uh if
they've got the content which they do
now to Showcase but if you're going to
use these shows also as a platform
absolutely right this is something that
a lot of us talk about in the community
for a long time the marketing aspect
getting out there and like addict said
to getting to different parts of the
world is always going to be important
for Microsoft and Xbox right it's always
going to be important Europe is you know
they're not they're not they're doing
good but they're not doing great right
and they want to change that so you got
to show up uh to some place like
Gamescom Germany and show what you got
and I think we are we're going to
probably get a couple surprises I think
age Empire's four uh for console would
be a great announcement here I know
everybody says knee genre but it's still
a big game
um and it is due up so age Empire's four
for console and I think they could have
something like a Hi-Fi Rush
um ready to rock and roll or just a
smaller game maybe a couple smaller
games on the on the horizon maybe some
European devs that they've teamed up
with that we don't know about yet
um yeah exactly exactly no doubt no
doubt pong I like what you're cooking up
Lord finds a rally
Gamescom Xbox is back what do you feel
you know the presence is what are you
expecting from them what would you like
um well given that by the time Gamescom
rolls around we should know about the
whole FTC ruling and everything
um they might have a lot more to show
them think about it I mean
if that were to happen I mean to show
the point uh not that I don't think they
wouldn't have anything to show for if
they if that deal doesn't go through
because if it doesn't I mean it really
changes nothing for us anyway much we
still get the games whatever we play we
just don't get them in gay pass but no I
think they have a lot to um offer us
still uh there's still games out there
they they can show more of uh namely
hellblade 2. actual gameplay might be
nice that would be really nice to do
they're gonna have to some combat
they've been working on that combat for
you know we've been hearing about it for
years now
um saying how much better the combat has
gotten we need to see that and I think
that would be a great place to show it I
mean that is the world stage for for
gaming right that is like the massive
World E3 essentially that that's the big
one so show us some gameplay show some
actually like that's what I want to see
there with hellblade too
um uh also I I think that they you know
have other games maybe that um uh were
unannounced so far they'll have an
announcement there maybe not a huge game
but some something on the smaller end uh
but exclusive to Xbox
um I'm just I'm not really looking at
this uh Gamescom and thinking we're
gonna see some crazy stuff okay
um from Xbox but I do think that they
can show a lot of good stuff for us and
get us excited still I really do no
doubt no doubt like what you cooking up
dead Lord King where you at man you boys
outside greeny's outside talking about
they're excited you know and continuing
the year of great things to show it
would be mentioned a year specifically
so where you at with Xbox and the big
thinking how does it throw the whole
we're gonna be holding the line of
German not us physically but Xbox is
gonna be Hold the Line in Germany
absolutely
my check
oh well funded oh I I just I'm well
funded
um
well respected
first um I I hit young dread in the DM
so we're gonna work
um I have to sign off I have to sign off
for it yeah I know I know I'm gonna keep
you in the loop on that oh you're gonna
keep him about my emoji
keep your face
you get the word okay okay
I've already seen a lot of drawings on
Twitter
make sure you approve those guys
do that but we got to make sure that
this brand um official yeah yeah yeah
say that there are a lot of talented
people yes yes absolutely young dread is
uh he's calling you up so maybe talent
for these beefy streets this is the
opportunity to uh break because I
usually have a real tight um group that
I work with like graphic god
um
[Music]
and so maybe we get some new Young
um about the Showcase her
there's a nothing Burger
yeah Microsoft is going to be a Gamescom
and they give you all the E3 stuff uh
remove all the fluff uh put uh like
whatever the extra days were consolidate
that and put that on the rail and throw
that up there and then you know
everybody's like yeah Microsoft had a
great show they might show a couple of
Indies and some deals that they had done
now here's the caveat this is the first
time that a big deal is pending uh of
Acquisitions going into the show right
so we feel that by by the end of next
week we should have some information on
the APK deal be it a goal be to know
right and it's a goal because I live on
positivity time it's a goal
you might have a change at the ship
little audible
you know you know Omaha
okay
formation look at the king go long pause
um so I think that might happen and I
think it it hinges on that so I'm gonna
give you the scenario that you know if
the ABK deal don't go through APK deals
don't go through show be just the same
thing as E3 all that stuff that was
there okay
ABK deal goes through you will have an
extended
welcoming because that's like a coming
out party right that's uh we're here the
other dudes aren't
and you really get the chance to to rub
it in their face because is it just a
little bit different remember the
opposition directly tried to oppose this
so this is where you actually get a
chance to grab they wound open it up and
throw a whole bunch of salt in it and
rub it in on the stage on a national
stage where they aren't there where they
told that demographic that they didn't
matter right so they're going to show
them that this demographic matters and
this deal matters and we're gonna rub it
in your world so real quick question
King if the deal goes through do they
announce the cards and Game Pass at
Gamescom it might happen that same day
they might wait to that day to stand on
stage and say go look at your game pass
now
get your Call of Duty on you know yeah
they might Diablo might drop
it will be a detrimental day for for a
certain fan base right
and I think and this is this is this is
just a little bit of talk here guys
after this deal goes through we already
know this is acquisition season the rise
of Sith Lord field and it's in effect
Tokyo game show oh
wouldn't it be wild to announce where
act we're acquiring Sega we go up the
Block is Hot I was thinking I was
thinking
no the block is not hot the block is not
hot the block is not hot don't ever
think the Block is Hot the deal is good
it's a good deal so they they get the
deal done
what better stage than to because
somebody is floundering in Japan oh man
yep in their backyard right and this is
Sith Lord spills finest moment he steps
on that stage and says
we are in talks to acquiring Sega and
comes out on the stage with uh Sega
Chief and this is what we're trying to
do next to take over where they left off
where where the other two the other team
abandoned Japan and I think that sends
everybody in the frenzy and uh little
black man's a soul all over Japan like
it's going out of style I think that's
where they make their Mark y'all looking
at Gamescom as the the the the the the
climax no I think that's the Catalyst to
the climax and the climax is uh Tokyo uh
game show wow you so you fresh out the
court that's right we run back in it
fresh off the federal investigation yes
that's right Teflon Don Federal Trade
and you literally gonna go make another
problem so write that in there and keep
it pushing yeah we acquired
and we still had money and you saw the
list guess who's next Baby You Got It
come on
curiosity King
if the deal doesn't go through
no no I I want your honest opinion if
the dough doesn't go through how much of
that money that they were initially
going to give Activision do you think
Microsoft okays for them to reinvest
into other stuff because I I don't think
it's all but I do think it's a good
portion of it would go we can't get
Activision let's look at other things
okay and I'm I'm gonna do it as a Layman
right I'm Gonna Act Like no business no
nothing okay
if I took five hundred dollars and I set
it aside for something and that
something fell through a five hundred
dollars was gone anyway so I'm gonna
take that 500 and invest it in other
aspects I think every last dollar of
that 70 and and be forewarned
the deal doesn't go through and it's
blocked by Sony
you have a Target on your head so you
have green you are green lit all right
in in the streets when there's a green
light on you that means y'all saw John
Wick coming out of the corner all over
they would we go get this bounty it's
they will acquire every and anything
possible you want to talk about the
stuff that y'all like to talk about that
stuff that y'all like to do buy
exclusive games and time that out and
leave a segment of the community out
Microsoft will take 70 billion dollars
at erase games from your platform since
y'all like to do that and FTC think
there's nothing wrong with that well all
the games that's coming out from every
third party let's send some cash they
win let's see how it works and that's
organic growth y'all like that right
it'll be so organic it will organically
fold you up put you in the coffin and I
can't wait to see them do that thing
then in it and ship y'all away yeah my
wrong Ally is gonna be lit if this deal
don't go through y'all just might as
well just sign it up it's over you
better let the deal go y'all better act
for that to happen that's a far less
worse fate than if the deal don't go
through who's doing that little dance
the PlayStation in the casket oh you're
talking about the B where they doing the
meme
this deal don't go through and boy do
you understand
how do you anger a trillion dollar
company with your billion dollar butt
[Music]
down before I make change oh baby you
don't know that Nino Brown
anyway yo I'm telling you he tried to
play nice this is the rise of Dolph Phil
it's oh it's it's completely over either
way it goes y'all an app anyway bro he
said this is the Vader origin story
right here yo think about it fonts
what's Invaders it wasn't wasn't Anakin
such a nice kid oh yeah yeah beautiful
right until they constantly did
different things to upset this man he
has the force he had the ability to
either go left or right and then uh Mace
Windu said yo don't train that dude
because if you give him power he can go
left to right and the anger they angered
this man you did y'all see Phil angry
when he did that interview yeah yeah and
and that power is that checkbook
is Satya being over there because he's
like
more
powerful let the evil flow through you
feel it take it I can't get this back to
you Phil
I can make you win Phil no he has the
ability to allow him to win oh man yo
I'm telling you and you know why I knew
it was that because when Satay was on
the stand and he said yes
I don't have any uh stake in that choice
that's young Phil beautiful
if young Phil wants to kill them lets
them die
you know Anakin and he slipped up he
goes I mean Phil
yeah I mean I see it Darth Vader at the
end is a sympathetic individual that a
lot of circumstances happen to him that
formed him into who he was and he felt
that his decision is right so this is
the rise of the empire you don't have to
get out and lay down these are hours and
we looking for it and you're on the
wrong side of History
[Laughter]
that's not
King acting like like it's like a
restaurant and they bring the steak it's
not cooked enough send it back
I love the movie he watching but oh you
know what it is it's like um attic and
you'll love this it's the restaurant we
took you to that Brazilian restaurant
yeah that was yeah I had nightmares of
that place to this day when you turn
that card over and there's a green light
and it keep letting me come
it's it's like I have a nightmare that
like I turn turn it over to have them
stop but it is green on both sides
you go to Brazilian Steakhouse
is that the place where they keep
bringing you the meat yeah the Brazilian
steakhouse
we'll take you there pong
because I don't eat meat plus right
right and addicts started catching the
meat sweats yes he never he I guess he
didn't know
but it's the wildest thing and I look
over at I mean he looks over at me
it'll be you know obviously I agree with
you that if the ABK deal the injunction
you know it doesn't you know go through
for the FTC that yeah there's a chance
they call it audible as far as you know
that acquisition and have maybe they
kind of fire up something quick whether
it be an Xbox wire post you know showing
the graphic right
I could see that kind of energy hey
maybe even something from the back of
that team or Game Pass like yo you know
immediately as of da da da this is it
here you know kind of like how Bethesda
was as far as like um Gamescom itself
it's a big deal I think it's big when
they actually have a show presence on
the floor when they're on the floor it's
a big deal you set up the booth that's
like that's for the fans yes that's
traditional E3 style this is not like a
online event pass through that means
that take in Germany and the EU very
seriously and they're spending thousands
of dollars with some people there
absolutely sending people out there you
see like pong said Phil made the state
you know I think that's big I think
we're also sleeping on forza's presence
I think Forza has to make a huge down
out there this is that I didn't like it
I didn't like what they did before right
you you yourself being mad I told I told
Maddie that you said that on Define the
Duke and I was like you know King's a
big four is a guy there's a people that
want
to the force Affairs defense the
Motorsport got a hardcore the simulation
got they didn't get the in depth that
they should have necessarily I
personally was fine with their friends
direct but it is a game that's coming
out this year this is the region that is
supposed to but shout out to my man
what's the forza Irwin and um you know
they get it in you know there's a
community that dick like I'm a horizon
guy but the Motorsport guys are a
different breed and that's the graphical
showcasing simulation base because I
didn't get sorry for cutting you off
because it's supposed to be a game of
service right and I didn't get what the
season pass would look like I didn't get
I heard
um the tire thing would change like the
rotation rear mode we don't really know
the details the grit right absolutely I
think we get turn 10 shows up there if I
had to guess and has a nice presence to
really give the you know the car
aficionados what they want and we got to
call you know look God Howard most
likely is going to be outside once they
say Bethesda Xbox and Bethesda there's
the premier title and I don't know about
y'all there's really nothing that
excites me this year Morningstar there's
nothing that you know so you know you
know how it is Starfield we're getting
close and we're getting close yeah two
months away you know they have some form
of a presence there it'll be interesting
to see how much that they divulge
because to add exploit you you know Todd
is kind of secretive they like to do
things their way but the thing I'm
noticing now that you're part of the
Xbox game studios you got to promote
this thing this is all hands on deck
from a promotional to build up this hype
train to get this thing going promo is
ready so I expect that to happen
um I'm with you um I forgot who said it
I think it was Fonz about Ninja Theory
um look I'm hoping the UK Studios
presence is strong whether it be
playground games with a little mate
maybe more Fable tidbits and Ninja
Theory especially now
conventional wisdom says Ninja Theory
might not be there only because they
might want to save combat for a
developer direct because they like
already showed it but hey Fox I'm with
you if you want to come out there and
show us another snippet where you know
sending what is actually hey I won't I
won't object because we all agree that
as much as we love Ninja Theory that
showcase showing of it was it it wasn't
it it gave it the show any minuses right
because think about this universe if if
selling one hell Blake 2 shows combat
and it's phenomenal we're talk we're
elevating that show even the show was
amazing already
in fact it could literally have been the
greatest show of all time for them if
said because we know what Ninja Theory
is selling us to do we kind of know
we're not really scared about what they
got you know what they're gonna do it's
like damn show it show it show it we
need to see that's the last question
kind of thing I I was so disappointed
bro I was yeah addict was
that was the slam dunk easily for them
but okay I think they've learned what
they need to do you know what I'm saying
and I'll see we'll see we'll see we'll
see if they learn we'll see if they
learn but that's pretty much what I got
on that and I do agree that we probably
get some Game Pass deals like I'm with
palm completely on maybe like games you
know European Focus type games with a
Game Pass deal kind of thing and that's
pretty much it but um yeah that's that's
what I got on the uh Gamescom press
anybody else before we move on I just
wanna do I read yeah yeah oh yeah I'll
do my reaction I want to make a quick
announcement real quick you know uh the
reason I walked away is because I I
locked General in the in the gym
Lord's holding likes for hostage okay
likes is General the the currency I want
to release that man's is like there's a
difference get it right all right okay
so so key we said a thousand didn't we
yeah
unless we got General attic
General attic is held up okay I said
I'll play Final Fantasy but you know
what I might give you a little snippet
of General General wasn't showing up
until after this FTC
um
Buck could definitely show up the Final
Fantasy because he did not show up but
shut up get those likes up to a thousand
then we could uh you know Buck out here
because Buck got to talk about the
financials
he said hey guys anybody's else Xbox
paycheck late came this week because we
had to check on it everybody how they
doing it no I got mine no I didn't okay
bro I gotta check in with payroll my bad
thank you for remembering no no forget
I'm gonna go check the mail I'll be back
doc is hilarious look you saw the video
about the Xbox app hit your rewards
button if you're part of the family you
know what you get
inside friends and family
you want me to get these super chats
before we move on please
okay so we got a two dollars icon up
right yeah well I don't got the new one
but uh oh I didn't I didn't put it in I
was yeah sorry about that we'll do it
for next week okay cool we got two two
dollar Super Chat from
Nintendo the uh Nintendo on the otaku
they all look good bad don't matter
tears of the kingdom is the goat two
dollar shift from uh Danny passion
official
uh iofr
gaming for 10 years of mobile game got
me back in uh I I guess he said he
didn't play games for a while in a
mobile game got back into the gaming uh
you got a member trap from the list 22
been a member for 29 months Long Live
snake and the Nokia 3310 yeah wow I had
the message by now I say on my ringtone
remember uh my audio filed back in the
day it was fired two dollar super trap
from uh Corey Tidwell yeah
made their option I'd rather play what
oh right yeah he said he'd rather play
redfall than uh Concord or
okay I would agree with that I think he
needs his temperature
we got it from Piper love the
professionalism
uh Got A Gifted from Matt
uh that's your name for the day he
gifted five uh memberships appreciate
that you know definitely get those put
those logos in the chat for those five
new members then we got a two dollars
per shot from official
uh young dress he said when y'all make
that beefy shirt don't forget
from Kings overrated
glad to see oh that's his name yeah
that's his name no no I know I was I was
uh zooming it up a little bit uh glad to
see the Lords on the Glorious Sunday
still recovering for the night of
democracy celebrating my fiance's
picking out a wedding dress iron Lords
is exactly what I need have a good day
Lords alone bro that must have been
rough to celebrate when she finally
picked out the dress she must have went
through a bunch to finally celebrate
when it happened you know how that go
bro yeah uh I don't know what currency
this but 100 it's black Viking just
watch a show some love for y'all and
tell y'all to keep grinding also call
did you commission Playboy picture of
you stuffed the chop to the Broom the
beefy pot we good with corporate car we
working on the busy Farm we don't we
don't know
from Jax 82 badge was an iconic
franchise but I saw what they did with
Donkey Kong Country Returns it's nothing
like the original I haven't been back to
uh they turned Diddy Kong into a jet
pack
what uh well that happened to banjo well
one Nintendo doesn't own banjo uh two
that's what they do on that side over
here we keep it authentic and you know
organic we got five dollar switch out
from God's Hitman what do you think
they'll announce at Gamescom I think
Phil might say everything that ABK owns
is now on Game Pass yes sir two dollar
Super Truck official young dress I'm
ready put me on the line General gotcha
okay
two dollar super trap from high I'm
sells a loud Spanish chick on the IOP
panel one day
that can't happen I think she's trying
to come on it's possible I don't know
from dreads thread I heard y'all talking
about beefy things hey Carl
whoa whoa whoa whoa never know what's
gonna be said here on this show
I think I don't I don't think we should
lean into this video
you know what it is though it was it was
the the um what was those those are
Speedos right it was just Speedo oh man
that that took it over that because when
you was in Cobra Cog with the suit I was
like yeah I'm feeling that then you saw
you on the side
yeah
because muscle got muscles
like hold on do I have that still yeah
we trust you
what y'all didn't see was this and this
is yeah I saw that out there and I'm
like they got my man's crazy
that is way too much that's a bit much
like a Streets of Rage boss
uh it's Phil Vader like Execute Order
66. five dollars you can't find me in to
push his cats for real king and Cog
beefy Loop they got us cashing checks
from Xbox and that little of that black
little man picking big TV we live in the
Lord's great show you're too awesome
truck from Harry Potter
get these likes up I need the original
Buck for Final Fantasy yeah we need that
over a thousand man we got two topics or
you're not gonna get Buck
pause pause
somebody tune in right when they were
showing the beefy pitcher and then
hearing attic say that oh we're done
we just went up 2 000 people exactly
maybe Microsoft delayed the next Elder
Scrolls from 20 uh from 2026 to have a
drop of the mic with the next console
surface
two dollars per shot from uh doctor
Strangelove
uh I'm gonna need a big juicy slab of
coffee right now wow
super trap from Spartan 661 I'm
surprised not hearing about the PS Huff
Brethren Cindy deep depicts to the judge
to get release dates to get release
dates out of her decision like they did
with the doc God of War uh God of War
two five dollars Super Chat from Corey
Tidwell I'm with Cog on this we need to
drop the beefy thing otherwise they're
gonna have to change the podcast
the iron Lords pause cast pause
all right now it's time to mute your
mics everybody mute there Mike it is
time for that uh special reading I'm
gonna check the mail again for my check
please do this episode of I lost podcast
is brought to you by better help have
you ever had moments in your life when
you just didn't know what to do and I
don't mean not knowing what's going for
dinner what outfit to wear at the club I
mean the big stuff like what's going on
in your life am I wasting my time dating
this person that's different from me or
just in general like I have a dream job
now or do I hate it the truth is
sometimes in life we are faced with
tough choices and the path isn't always
clear whether you're dealing with
decisions around career relationships or
anything else therapy helps you stay
connected with what you really want
while you navigate life so you can move
forward through confidence and
excitement trust yourself to make
decisions that align with your values is
like anything the more you practice it
the easier it gets for me there's been
plenty of moments in my life that with
hindsight I recognize I could have
handled a bit better whether it be my
lack of experience or maturity at the
time and the fact that I didn't
necessarily prepare possess the tools
necessary to understand the situation
ahead so I was inequipped to make smart
decisions and sometimes was ultimately
left to cope with the extreme
consequences of my actions when I
finally showed out therapy and talking
to someone I have to say it really
helped me immensely to focus on the
positive the end results properly kind
of dealing with toxic situations while
not getting drowned out with the
day-to-day you know emotional and
physical aspects Financial aspects of uh
of life so I've also learned
organizational coping skills and how to
set boundaries and empowered me to
strive to be the very best version of
myself the great thing is very effective
to help us to deal with the stresses and
anxieties of our day-to-day lives so if
you're starting to think about you know
starting therapy I strongly recommend
giving better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
just fill out a brief question there to
get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional course let
therapy be a map with better help visit
betterhelp.com iron Lords today to get
10 off your first month that's better
help
h-e-l-p.com slash Iron Lords and I'm
going to need better help for the beef
shaming
[Laughter]
all jokes aside now this is real real
talk and um salute to solve as well you
know we we definitely co-sign you know I
know it's not cool you know men thinking
you know we got problems it's supposed
to be like some serious mental issue but
no it's real therapy is real there's no
shame in it and addressing the stuff as
a man is real talk so that's all I got
okay well what I feel about it and I
think the easy ease of use as far as
going from a therapist that let's say
you don't click with that therapist
right
um and the ability to switch a therapist
without going to this office and going
to that office I think that helps a lot
because uh it was a period of time where
I needed to unload and especially during
the covert time when they had everybody
isolated and a lot of things weren't
going right for you and you know social
media doesn't help because sometimes you
look at somebody's timeline and having
the time of their life and you think
what's going on with my life can you
start questioning things about yourself
so sometimes you need to uh release and
have an unbiased uh words given back to
you because you have a family group base
that you have you have a salad
Foundation I have friends and family but
sometimes they don't want to hurt my
feelings they don't want to tell me
something that is obviously
a change that I need to make and you
know they don't they know I'm not ready
for it or whatever their tool invested
they're too close to the flame the
therapist is a unbiased individual that
is trained faction it will give you
techniques to uh help you along in your
journey so it helped me immensely trust
me when I tell you it took me out of a
lot of dark areas and it was very
helpful so you know this this is a real
good thing and I'm glad y'all got a
chance to you know use our code no
absolutely and last thing I want to say
is that for people who definitely
struggle with it the online part is
important because sometimes be a lot of
people that won't go in there sit on
somebody chair look at some strange you
know let's be real a lot of us is man we
go through that yeah and then as men
sometimes we a little too tough right
we're a little oh we got it bro and you
can't cry yeah
so I get it for those interested it's
discreet I'm putting a link in the chat
again for anybody do it at your own
discretion you know what I'm saying and
you just you know go out there and then
you know five of the beefy Chronicles
like I did but anyway yeah if there's
anything that we definitely 100 believe
in is mental health yes absolutely what
I would uh especially Gamers is you
cover that window that's on the opposite
side of your posters so we can get a
chance to see what your posters look
like yeah because the windows reflected
yeah oh yeah I told Carl like before I
had to go get some yeah that's good it's
all good all right so we're gonna move
go out there walking around you know
being beefy
sometimes I just sit in the middle oh
come on not to cast the couch you look
past in the West Virginia House an
addict just walking past I like when he
do that arm thing and legs spread out
without doing casting couch and you were
watching the pause cast
a fish
we gonna move on to this topic you
already know that this was all brother
sovereign's topic he's a big red dead
fan and the rumors are swirling Red Dead
Redemption big fan too yeah that's right
you're the perfect person for this
absolutely Yeah man so we got uh again
shout out to gaming route right now
basically saying that oh Red Dead
Redemption remastered might release
imminently with an announcement in
August and this comes up from a new
rating by um Korea's game rating and
administration community so the
speculation is really right right now
and then our very own LSM fan Colin
Moriarty friend of the realm pretty much
lay down the the rumor confirmed so he
said they've been hinting at the
existence of this remaster and then one
of the episodes of our sacred symbols
and Colin Basie stated that the remaster
of the 2010 released masterpieces in the
works and an official announcement can
be imminent so we start to see things
bubbling potentially that red dead could
become coming back let's start with
Falls man you are definitely Lord Red
Dead this is one of your favorite games
let's talk about it man uh love the
franchise love both uh redhead 2 and the
original
um uh you know I I've got I've got mixed
feelings on this honestly uh
now this is a remaster right this is
what's
rumored
um if it's not really like a total
remake do I really want to remaster you
know I I've played this game on the 1X
even and it looked great there you know
yeah
um with their backwards compat looked
felt pretty good
um so a remaster for this game isn't
really doing it for me like they've got
to really push the envelope here for
this game and give the love and
attention it deserves like this game to
me is Iconic this game to many people is
Iconic
um Red Dead Redemption is is honestly
one of the best uh third person action
adventure open world games ever period
um and Rockstar they definitely know how
to do that and they definitely know how
to push the envelope with these games
like I expect them with GTA 6 to go all
out and we're going to see things we
haven't seen done in other games before
so push the envelope a little bit here
give us a total remake that's what I
want give us something that looks
incredible maybe on a new engine uh you
know even unreal five whatever just to
make this look incredible and play
incredible feel incredible especially us
guys on Console yeah yeah yeah please
Red Dead one or two what do you ragtime
uh Red Dead Two okay okay
um and it's because
uh honestly redhead is an amazing story
uh but both have great stories
um and at the at the time before Red
Dead 2 came out I was thinking to myself
there's no way John Marston as a
protagonist can ever be one-upped but
then Arthur Morgan comes along it just
UPS him and and and I love both actors
so much I love what they did with these
characters but Arthur Morgan was just
such a likable character for Red Dead 2
that it just it drew me in even more and
that's what good acting can do in these
games right they can really pull you
into the game
um get you immersed and that's what he
did uh I forgot the gentleman's name who
voice acted him God I can't remember but
I remember I I tweeted I dm'd him as
soon as the game dropped and I was I I
finished the game
um I dm'd him and he DM him back and I
was blown away oh it was Roger Clark
a shout out to him great freaking acting
in that game
um so I yeah for me Red Dead 2 is the
better game
um overall but both are classic both are
amazing and I would definitely play even
red dead too if they gave me a 60 frames
mode
pretty it still holds up I mean
graphically graphically it's still
amazing things you can play period right
now so now which which
is The Soul Man wait where you at as far
as uh Red Dead your your thoughts on
this potential remaster just your
association with the series yeah Red
Dead Redemption mode is one of my
all-time goats so it's it's a top ten
game for me all time I John Marsden will
never be topped uh liked Arthur Morgan
uh but not the same as John and I always
lean this way so people understand I
usually lean towards the original I'm a
Mass Effect one guy oh you want it I'm
guys yeah I'm one of them guys one of
them one yeah I am one of them I give
bonus points for the further started
everything but just for me I love John
Marsden so
he is he's famous he's fantastic the
story was freaking amazing
um I think that you know when it comes
to Rockstar
I'm I'm I want this to happen for sure
right but what they did to grant them I
knew this was coming listen you can't do
that don't do that and push this out the
door and say yep we did something for
y'all cash grab yeah yeah yeah no no no
no no no no no no no no no no you got to
do it right you got to treat these
that's the one thing I do have a problem
with if you are as a publisher and this
goes for anybody if you're going to do
this if you're going to do a remaster or
remake either way if you're not going to
respect it's like the game's history and
what it means in the place of history
with gamers in particular and you're not
going to treat it with that level that
it's due to that game like a Red Dead
Redemption they just don't do it then
just leave it the way it is let it you
know let it be the what it was at the
time and don't touch it now again we've
seen great things you know go back to
the Mass Effect Trilogy remake oh yes
legendary edition come on ABS again EA
of all places just did it right right so
um I want to see Rockstar do this the
right way but if they are going to do it
even though that's not a remake if it's
a remaster if they can bump the Fidelity
if they can give me the frames if they
include Undead Nightmare one of the
greatest deals
okay absolutely then do this I will be
excited I will be first in line I will
pick it up day one for sure so I I do
have excitement but I'm I'm tempered
because of what they did to GTA right uh
okay great that's a great Point yeah
that's a great way so pretty much you
got a little okay you you don't trust
them all the way after what happened
minimum I'm assuming you want pong 4K 60
or like correct correct yeah absolutely
and that type of game if you're gonna
remastered yeah do that do the right way
to do that yeah addict the Lord of Red
Dead and horses this is his game he's so
pumped oh my God so hyped yo what are
you feeling about a red dead remaster
that's how he's feeling back to you Jill
it comes down to us like I hope like you
know funds and solve get the type of
game that they want uh
they could literally they could have
announced anything and I would have been
more excited there's no Yeehaw in you
bro I would prefer to see another Tetris
before Oh man don't do it why do you
hate we gotta get why do you hate I
didn't even go that hard on Banjo yeah
so because you didn't I'ma go extra hard
on right now
have unnecessary haters
doesn't resonate with me no I don't even
really like GTA like that anymore so
it's just like so are you a holy guy
addict
did you like it was fun I would like it
blue is all right yeah so it's like I
hope the people that want the game get
it but like I said I I would I would
prefer to like rip my eyeballs out
before I play it so no cowboy games ever
none never like not really I try to play
Red Dead too okay but then I got killed
by a bear because I got on the horse and
when I got off the horse they just
naturally stationed all my weapons and
didn't tell me and I went to pull out a
gun and I had none and then the bear ate
me and then I uninstalled it
it looks
like the horse was stealing people's
guns oh man it is
Lord King another fellow red Red Dead
you know connoisseur of man of culture
while I used to watch The Westerns you
know what I'm saying Bonanza come on
Good Bad and the Ugly let's go this is
ugly let's go oh no let's watch all the
music come on if if they can put this
game on Red Dead uh two's engine
[Music]
um and get it out the door because I
thought the Fidelity on Red Dead too all
right thank you
outside bro
that's the other one yeah that's a whole
different horse sex situation but
um I I loved the living environment I
thought the the world felt lived in yes
all right
um the historian narrative gave uh
Spaghetti Westerns uh they they just do
like if you grew up in that era you know
you know watching John Wayne meet me at
the okay Corral twists
come on that's the Alamo like you know
uh Clint Eastwood if if you're Clint
Eastwood fan and not to get off my lawn
dude not that dude I'm talking about my
day cleaning
um you would love Red Dead games right
now the first one built up such a cult
following that the DLC is probably
arguably
one of the greatest DLCs that ever
dropped for an existing game because
either it surpassed the game or it met
the game at the same level and the value
for that was incredible real quick
talking about like Clinton Eastwood
because I missed all that nonsense that
you just said like in terms of his
movies was that the same like dude that
played in that uh movie Gran Torino yes
okay I like that that was a good movie
okay so you need to go back and watch
when he was young yes start with the
outlaw Josie Wales
you lost me at Homework you know
like westerns you can watch uh what
What's he called um Dirty Harry
talk to you Joe
yo my my my growing up I used to watch
The Lone Ranger
Love The Lone Ranger love the Tonto and
Lone Ranger let's go when I get a chance
to play this game this is the feelings
that I got so I do and I can say this in
all honesty I did like Red Dead 2 more
than I like red dead one because
um and I thought it was just a little
they refined a lot of things made the
shooting a lot better
the AI was more intelligent of course
because of the years that passed and the
things that they learned but I am with
the panel oh I'll Rush this out to get
to this right don't don't make this a
sacrificial lamp to you know uh Grand
Theft
um and don't don't don't do anything
half behind yeah I think I think that's
where I'm at too King it's like if
you're gonna do something do it because
you generally want to give a good
product that ends up leading to a lot of
money don't do something to try to make
a lot of money that ends up with a less
product yeah from the name don't don't
go out there and just use his name and
capitalize off the um the the what is it
um what what do we The Nostalgia of the
old game let's just put out a decent
project so if it's not and I'm with
funds if it's not a remake
that's true let's not give a remaster of
the same game you know uh we already got
bad compat over here so I'm sorry for a
lot of you other dudes that don't got
back patent you know uh your engineers
not as good as Jason Ronald and that
game looked and played phenomenally yeah
but does this on all platforms though
you know so this might be a PlayStation
thing no you know maybe the upred
version for them well if all they have
is PlayStation indeed yeah if they love
the game they're gonna need that they
need it
but we over here we eating good so um
get us a remake
us at the Xbox delegation
opposed to a remaster we don't want you
to remaster anything we already got that
we need to remake 4K 60
Red Dead 2 engine and make sure the DLC
is thrown in there for free yes yes for
sure because you're gonna charge 70. so
I want the whole thing to get deluxe
edition absolutely
if they do that they're selling 10 to 20
million oh they would be it would be
easy
yeah put it in Game Pass
okay we gotta see about that we don't
know how uh but that might be that thing
I do think they're going to be very
hesitant uh consumers Will based on what
they did with the GTA Trilogy and yes
that's yeah and rightly so because I'm
gonna side eye this game too you know
this remaster uh like I said I really
want a remake I don't want a remaster I
want something that adds something new
to to the game you know I just I don't
want the same old game you know and I
love the game I I would replay it for
sure but I want new stuff added in to
these older games
I feel you but I think you changed my
position
I'm like damn I'm kind of right I'm
basically getting tired of a lot of
these remasters I think I think um
they're just too much of the same my
issue with the type of consoles we have
now is you could easily give us what you
try to sell us for free in a patch so
it's just like either
follow line with Capcom is doing with
Resident Evil is what the company that
made um yeah dead space or just give us
a patch and shut up damn like because
that's where I'm at with them like I'm
tired of people trying got the back
patch with the Xbox this is a com the
place conversation bro like they are the
ones over there this is they they the
ones that left out in the cold they
don't know like you don't know we living
real good when we say we living good old
games look new again over here over
there yeah um
let it sound
so this is really a cash grab for them
really and and I like it when y'all say
oh the game sell more over here
yeah because you got to do it because we
already got back to pack our stuff
Looking ready good we don't need to go
out and buy the same game again y'all do
though y'all have four of the same
copies
the remaster the remaster the remaster
the remake of the remastered y'all the
team of that I love y'all y'all
consistent
consistency leads to longevity keep
going I came out with you yo
is a very huge thank you absolutely it
really is absolutely yeah come on 100
you know Jason Valentine magicians just
the great wizard you know saying behind
everybody Xbox Tech but um yeah I think
fine swayed me man I think yeah like now
that I think about it like how cool
would it be to see it in ue5 yes
and not necessarily even ue5 just even
an updated engine uh what what were they
using um you know for Red Dead two
why am I thinking maybe I'm wrong maybe
I thought it was Unreal but chat correct
me if I'm wrong like what was um Red
Dead 2's engine we got three bit in
there we got fun speculation we got some
techie people in there what was the
engine red dead two years
proprietary was it rage yeah yeah I
think it's proprietary okay it's the
rage engine okay and that rage engine is
beast mode yeah whatever they're using
it Red Dead 2 looked great make it look
like that you know the engine was
definitely beefy
I'm never I'm never I'm never gonna get
used to it and it's funny as hell
because it just came out of nowhere and
that's organic growth
appreciate y'all anyway
um yeah it would be it'll be late to see
that you know in this form kind of
update I can't believe he did that
that was that was uh yeah out of pocket
yeah you took it here and King just took
it yeah he went all the way all the way
that was that was worth the million
bucks yeah I'm I'm DLC
hit that like button I definitely agree
on Garner then on guarding them
we we know it's illusion we got him in
there so look yeah other than that the
only thing I would say
um I am disappointed again I think Fawn
said this how red did it too ain't got
no 60 frames Moto console yeah hot is
coming before the 60 frames Mode for Red
Dead Two and I wanted to speak that's
why I wish you all remember I think this
was two two or three years ago yeah a
rock star was kicking around a rumor
that they were remastering Red Dead 2
for these new consoles and then they
took it away from us like
yeah like that little bully on the
playground taking his ball and going
home you know is not necessary the game
is really good I think if the online
would have took off like uh gtas online
then the finances will beat it to funnel
that into that project I don't think
well guess what the fight the finances
that are there for the GTA online they
can funnel right into red dead too all
right so let me actually yes they can
pay for the next 20 games with what that
game correct but let me ask y'all a
question this right
would you want them to take all the
money that they make from final um from
final from um
GTA 5
to put it into GTA 6. to make GTA 6
that feeling that because you know GTA 5
was really good and online is really
great
but they have to surpass that in some
form of fashion would you rather them
take all that money put it there or
split the pot
and put half hair give you an upgraded
five and uh upgraded uh Red Dead 2.
but it wouldn't take that it's not about
splitting yeah it's not about splitting
the pot they've made so many billions
that these games aren't boats it's it's
changing the bucket for them okay it's
literally uh they've made so much money
on GTA 5 and that's why they continue to
put out DLC they have made they've made
more money than a lot of small countries
have like but funds I asked this because
a subpart GTA 6 oh there won't be
detrimental yeah to what GTA 5 built you
can stop that money training very easy
by not surpassing what the money train
is bringing I I get you and and I don't
see this game being in any way do you
remember a few years ago when we saw the
leaks of like the pre-alpha and it
already looked better than some games
that's true yeah it's I had to go back
and scrap that yeah and it's crazy that
so they say to even think that they
wouldn't that they would come out with a
subpar GTA 6. I think they're going to
be really pushing the envelope on this
game I think GTA 6 is going to be one of
those games to where you're gonna say
now this is next Generation I hope so I
think that's going to be a graphic
stunner and that's why I'm like 50
frames I hope but that's why I just felt
bad that it got leaked though phones I
just felt yeah I was I was upset
hostage yeah people yeah social media
gonna pick apart every little frame
every little thing and you don't know
what stage the game is pre-alpha like it
I mean everybody's still going to be
there it's GTA everybody is the biggest
problem with that sorry Paul no no
problem with that wasn't the fact that
they leaked and shown it was the fact
that he had the source injured yeah yeah
yeah looking for ransom yeah
so he is it wasn't like he got a video
file and put a video file out no he got
the actual file of the game had the
sauce and the code so that was the
bigger problem than anything else and
that was detrimental in quick sidebar
here Ford GTA 6 I think one of the
things they're really going to improve
upon in my opinion what I think they're
really going to push is AI and I think
AI is doing really pushed in this game
because they've already had some of the
best AI in GTA 5 and all the GTA games
if you go back to the very first one
even for the time the just the
interactions you got with NPCs and stuff
was on a different level better than hot
coffee
oh yeah because they knew which ones had
that in there
the interactions you'll have with the
NPCs will get way more advanced I think
we're going to have so much
you might well I there's already rumors
out there about the the the clubs and
stuff yeah so about that
your hot coffee for sure for sure
two-year Point funds is that uh take two
did come out I think it was a year and a
half two years ago and was touting Cloud
AI that they had made a large investment
into that and that that was something
they were looking into obviously
implementing into the games down the
road and I would not doubt that yeah
that GTA 6 is one of the first ones
that's the thing that about Rockstar is
they always push the bar higher and
higher for themselves they always get
better and I believe that AI is that
next I'm I'm terrified
now I gotta talk stupid I don't
about the future of video games is AI
and how we interact with the world and
the NPCs themselves I mean yes that is
the big push in Innovation and sure
animation can get pushed as well and get
better but that AI the interactions you
have within games
I'm a graphics [__]
um
so
farther all right I think that coffee
will take you further okay but I need
that 4K 60 salad though
4K necessarily I'll take the 1440p 60. I
feel that give up okay I'm with you on
that but give me that whole high
fidelity thing to make me feel my
eyeballs
that make me think it's 4K but give me
60. hey there's some games out there at
1080 with uh with the graphics being
pushed to those High settings on console
that look really good at 60 frames fine
I go I go one better there's a current
game right now that lost the top spot
that is 7 20. oh I do I know right where
he was doing
like the way most of these games are are
using 720p using FSR to kind of upres
the graph most of them look blurry yeah
they don't sort of motion blur too
we gain that is
I can't oh hey they talk about that
might be game of the year so I think we
are trending backwards kind of in a lot
of ways we are and that's because we're
they're trying to push Tech forward and
they're trying to use things like rage
racing Global illumination and things
like that within the games that these
consoles themselves can't really handle
at this time bonds I think is more
nefarious than that I think we have
watched the rise of tcl's uh uh Paris in
the chat don't do them like that and I
think tcl's AI has uh
why is the television manufacturer is
the problem you know as dumb down old
again
I'm not gonna lie everything in me wants
TCO to offer him a big yes he
want to see
much it gonna take before King like I
rock that
same thing you need to do is send me an
88 inch television
chat he's right here TCL for life
it's not that bad
no they're terrible
um
88 inch uh Nano whatever the top of the
line right all right yes send that to me
unboxing okay and I want a white glove
it and then I'll talk about it and I'm
not sending it back
because I know a lot of you dudes y'all
get a product they tell you unboxing Spa
shine and send it back I ain't sending
nothing back but if you keep the TV
you're good go stay here so if you want
me to rap you TCL Paris Lily make it
happen the Lords need this TC yes so I
can use my Volari pillows
there we go y'all heard what needs to be
done Realm go get the pillows because we
almost finished with our pillows right
why is TCO the problem with this
generation
because TCL televisions can't handle the
truth
anytime you can pick your TV up out the
door next to the popcorn
oh man you're not doing this morning
right by the front door right you doing
the Costco energy come on kids let's
keep it a buck those are the ones they
don't care are stolen oh
yeah
he took the TV was it the TCL in the
entrance yeah okay let him know they did
us a favor
let's let's keep it a buck if you go to
any of your friend's house and they pull
out a 500
PlayStation 5. and the TV costs 300 and
it's a TCL a western house
oh do not compare TCL to Westing it's
dope but a day in the same group
and if I go in your house and I see that
I'm not sitting down
here man I don't like the way he said
I'm not sitting down like this because
you know you talk like wow we got that
Xbox money right
that's Xbox dude don't do that oh we
don't do that and you notice I said a
PlayStation 5 right because these dudes
would be so happy to have their
PlayStation 5 overheat standing right
next to their Westinghouse and you know
how the Westin house warp a little bit
oh man but TCL doing better I I used the
T-shirt I used the TCL for a couple of
months and what happened then I I I I
got a an LG and yeah
it got bigger I went out and bought
better uh-huh
soon as the cash came he threw it right
out that's that's you know that's a I'ma
hold you down for right now I need to
see something oh man
none of your friends saw it I'm very I'm
very picky when it comes to that kind of
tech with TV tech and special so yeah I
know there's levels to it I know
so we know TCL down here
and you went and got that
the Westinghouse was horrible that that
was on the level of RCA TVs
terrible TVs
he said this is hurtful
yo so if y'all in the chat and y'all
look at your TV and your TV said Weston
House
on TCL you understand when you stand
with me don't invite me over
we have a very educated audience and I
believe and I have faith in them now
y'all might have a high sense or TCL in
the garage
at a backyard TV
in the backyard just in case somebody's
still out
you're not the outside cookout TV
no don't do them like that it don't even
work outside it's not bright enough oh
it's true
kick David can be funded well with your
spots they're all underneath a tarp
they under a garbage bag you got two
guys
oh
moving on anyway we're done with this
time you can only make it you can only
put a TCL building and an old dumpster
fire anyway
all right uh
we got a lot we got that yeah let's get
that and then the ad read after kick
with Mexican I'm gonna take a break
all right [__]
I was talk Talking why funds
talking well I'll talk to the dog before
you find something you good I'm looking
through all the Super Shots oh it's that
many
yes oh somebody says Zenith bread I've
never seen it is lit Vizio somebody said
Vizio also don't do it
no that's that Costco stuff somebody
said hi says Dolby Digital
okay LGC yeah
hold up hold up hold up hold up I I
found it all right
Jack's 82 y'all trying to turn Cog into
an escort stop it
hey yo
two dollar Super Chat from Doctor
Strange I'm gonna need uh
a big juicy slab of cogs beef right now
oh man bro oh my God what's what's his
name Dr Strangelove
yeah but I'm pretty sure
okay I said I read that one God giving
people meat sweats
[Laughter]
okay fine I'll keep that from uh dragon
heart Yobe beefy uh beefy is Cox Tripper
name Got That Beef for you man all day
and woman response my man
uh
hi I'm cells thank you for spreading
mental awareness health awareness I
appreciate that we got a member chat
from gaming Forte better member for 42
months over two years uh I support a lot
of things but beefy [__] ain't it but
hey who do I know so while we're
celebrating things beefy
hey King Boo Boo okay
from Pixel bit G they got called looking
like biscuit Oliver from bonkey uh
yeah yeah yeah biscuit Oliver if you
finish watching Baki you would have
known that way I ain't finished watching
that I know I dropped that really fast I
think I've seen it I'd rather play I'd
rather play anywhere I watch that show
okay you would love Baki bro
all right final Swift draft from hargi
Shani see Pony Cog is out here trying to
help you use Better Health get some
sanity back in your life this is what a
legal sponsorship looks like oh man wow
for Nintendo Dom the otaku daily
reminder that Red Dead 2 is trash
and while I'm addicted too strong yeah
yeah yeah that's the only one shout out
to Red Dead one though that's a good
game
I don't know what the game is yeah from
Rich pee
what about the odds ABK going to uh
games going to Game Pass day one pretty
pretty good I would say pretty good
final subscribe from Michael Kelly just
stopping in on my born day to show some
love 41 laps around the Sun ain't broke
for me uh broke me yet back to Destiny
grind though all praise Lords happy
birthday happy born day yes man I feel
bad for you but you know on your
birthday you're grinding in destiny five
dollar suit trap from butterballs eight
the game never came to PC it would not
uh it would nice to have I don't know
yeah
probably yeah
I only want Rockstar to remake Max Payne
three no I want him to do that too I
wonder
uh on all of them Nintendo on the otaku
rock star is dead to me for canceling
bully two my name's attic and I prove
them I don't think it's canceled
I got two dollar subscribed from Lord
Metro bring the high of the hot coffee I
have cream
major pause
major pause I know what you're doing sir
continue
360 double TCR
360.
oh man find out super trap from
Butterball eight elements TV show
where's the TCO
oh yeah elements uh they yeah yeah
that's like Westinghouse element is on
par with Westinghouse that's like Red
Dead Redemption
that TV is under a hundred dollars could
you please don't bring that up
get that we got a
we gotta find out subscribe from Corey
Tidwell these cheap TVs always have
janky remotes hit the power button in
your garbage
your garage over here
from Elemento po Peter Marcos can sell
anything so anyone sand in the desert
we're gonna talk about him in a second
uh two dollars Super Chat uh from driven
drive by Joe I did hear Cog was an ally
now
Elemental po Final Fantasy 16 not so
great after last week night uh Knight
alike and I wish raindrops would fit oh
my fall oh yeah getting stuff done
called The Barber Beefcake
oh remember that Brutus yeah
when he came out the little hat back in
the day yeah with the hat the shoes I do
want to point out that uh you know we
got one topic until we hit that Final
Fantasy 16 South so if you want to see
[__] you better hit that like button we
got to get that over a thousand likes or
[__] it will be remained in the cellar
we'll keep him out of the out of the
podcast Stream So if you want to see
Buck hit that like button or you ain't
seeing but no the Super Chat don't you
gotta allow [__] the [__] up on you
pause
to 199 All-Star don't forget GTA 5 came
out at the end of the PS3 Slash 360
error they really pushes the the
consoles with their Ai and Graphics I'm
looking forward to what they do with the
new consoles
hit that like button guys you guys are
almost there we gotta pay the bills oh
okay hold on so you won't pay the bills
you gotta you don't get that paid you
know what I'm saying I'm gonna go check
the mail for that check again go get
funded I will get everybody ready before
when King's ready
all right after years of fine print
contracts getting ripped off by the big
Wireless providers if you learned
anything is that there's always a catch
so when I first heard that mint mobile
was offering premium Wireless starting
at 15 bucks a month I thought what's the
catch
but after talking to him and using their
service it all made sense there wasn't
one mint mobile secret sources that
they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only they cut
out the cost of the retail stores and
pass those sweet savings on to you now I
picked up a phone and um it was an
unlocked phone that's the first time
I've ever did this because you know my
son is uh with me now and I needed to
have constant contact with them so I was
going to add them on to my phone plan
but I saw the mint mobile thing and I
said let me try this so I got to unlock
phone and I added the mint mobile to it
the quality of the service is insane
like I couldn't believe it because I'm
talking to him it's very clear you would
think it would be Jank but it wasn't no
Jank it was really good service
um and it's 15 bucks so
for anyone who hates their phone bill
meant mobile offers premium Wireless for
just 15 bucks a month mint mobile gives
you the best rate whether you're buying
for one or a family and mint mobile
families start at two lines all plans
come with unlimited talk text and high
speed data delivered at the nation's
largest 5G Network use your own phone
with any mint Mobile plan and keep your
same number
along with all your existing contacts
switch to Mint mobile and get the
premium service starting at just 15
bucks a month to get your new Wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month and get
the plan shipped to your door for free
go to metmobile.com iron Lords with an S
that's cementmobile.com iron Lords with
an S cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com
iron Lords with an S way to ask y'all
y'all heard that I'm going up there with
that regular iron go without regular
iron so what's this been over this is
the drink with the foam and you get it
get it popping you're using it yeah so
um I ordered the phone right and this is
the first time I do it usually I do the
same thing because we like sheep and we
go inside the store and we go pick up a
phone we get the phone plan we walk out
and I build like five hundred dollars
yeah yeah so I picked up a phone and
this might be the TCL the phone phone
but he's 12 years old okay right so but
it was a Samsung and I got a Samsung
Galaxy and it's the lowest lower end
special Galaxy so um it up and I said um
let me put them at Mobile on it okay
right so you know when you go to the
store you have a question FaceTime tell
them FaceTime me he FaceTime me clear as
hell now sometimes I FaceTime my wife we
on the same T-Mobile plan brah I joined
us all uh the staticky and cracking I'm
like yo what's going on I gotta update
your phone or something what's going on
service but this service is really clear
and I was getting
um signal when we was in uh the mall you
know sometimes you don't get service in
the mall so that's why you got to jump
on that individual uh Wi-Fi in the
facility yeah you didn't have to with
him he was just getting service
automatically so I don't know how they
do it it's like magic but listen go to
uhmintmobile.com uh forward slash Iron
put the link in there and you know try
it out I'm gonna tell you right now it
might change your bills go and it's good
for like
you know you you got kids you get into
the age where they should really have a
means of communication and it's that
that price point where they you feel
safe with them having means of
communication but it doesn't break the
bank yeah no doubt G maybe say if you go
to Mint mobile king can he he maybe he
could afford the better than a TCL in
his room yes
yes and I'm gonna tell you right now
don't talk to me about your TCL in your
room that's shame sir oh baby hold your
shame in your channel
we gonna move on it's a fun one um this
is me oh
shut up
boom back outside teasing a new project
with ideas that have never been seen
before in a game well shout out to
Eurogamer with the story legendary
developer Peter Mountain will discussed
that next project so uh we spoke to game
reactor at the current at the recent
game ad conference in Barcelona Peter
Marlon was reluctant to give many firm
details of the game or or this to all
the idea to avoid in his word people
subsequently getting very annoyed and
angry when their expectations of his
words are not met for the reality he
said in days gone by I would just start
telling you about the whole game and the
whole game design and why it was going
to be the most brilliant game in the
world he said I'm not going to do that
what he did say was that this all new
mechanic would be part of a more
familiar environment and it was more
like a kind of fable black and white
Dungeon Keeper kind of experience so
this project is planned for PC and
consoles and um rather than other the
other topic the other titles that he was
at his office studio called 22 cans and
um that was born around like smartphones
and stuff so yeah this is um the project
you know that he hopes to materialize
obviously we know his history as far as
you know uh Quebec game remember he had
favorite Journey obviously responsible
for the Fable games and lionhead and all
that other stuff and um yeah his last
comments were kind of like we're
definitely leaning on PC and console
mainly because you need the power so
um I'm gonna jump in on this
because this is interesting to me you
know look on one hand you know Peter
malinux the legend right made Fable you
know he has you know I remember him
actually King you see if you we go back
from from populus I remember this was
like a over-the-top kind of God creation
type of game and stuff like that so but
there's one thing
that I can't give him from and I can't
let go
you know where I'm going and King you
remember it like it was yesterday it was
E3 2009 here we go and me and you walked
away from this connect demo with this
little boy and it was called Milo Milo
and it was called project natal yep and
the technology that was advertised was
so if if the technology was to be as
described it was literally better than
Jeep chat gbt
he had a little real life boy in the
game having full conversations with a
person
um independent thought the kid had a
motion smile with the remember he was
walking around yeah
all snake oil
she drew the picture for us of a fish
put it to the connect
Milo grabbed it in the game had the same
picture now apparently that part I heard
was real that part I heard the connect
can actually replicate I actually heard
that but I could not believe it yo I've
never did it happen
that's all I gotta say did it happen
because it never came out it never came
up it came to fruition I wonder why I
think that's the first time y'all know
I'm a tacky kick that's the first time
Texas it blew me away it scared me we
used to call it it was the devil in the
Box remember kids we had an expression
for it we're just like that's this
there's no way that that's sorcery what
is happening here right and it was the
initial trailer had crazy views listen
shout out to Tim though actually the
first time I met Tim though he had a
project in the tall show and I knew what
it meant I was like yeah you're being
funny but look this man is literally the
realest salesman of a video you cannot
say as far as selling a video game
no one sells a game better than peanut
butter I got you winners I mean it's
easy to sell stuff when you lie I got
you in this month thank you attic all
I'm saying is we got he is a forefather
of AI he is a forefather AI video game
and but I I gotta I know where y'all
gonna go I just gonna get my balls up is
that the over promises the over promises
were just so out of pocket and obviously
we know about the fate of Lionhead and
all that other stuff but um yeah he's
back outside man he's back outside and
to your point
um fonds about the Milo there was a TED
Talk he did
way after because gay got canceled about
you know Microsoft and the whole bedroom
and he did a TED Talk and apparently at
that time he was like yeah it was a
trick outright I'm like yo and then like
the the final version of Milo or project
Dimitri whatever was kind of different
it was like tidying up the boy's house
and it was a prompt that would say okay
what do you want Milo this it was just
it was different but anyway so look
Peter's outside how are we feeling
you know actually I do want to break
protocol I want to start with attic
first because
this is technically addicts for me man
though like that he makes one of your
favorite games
one of my favorite games but he made
Fable the literally you told me if it
was Fable got you into the Xbox
ecosystem not Halo so this is your
Legend this is your hero he ran into the
ground but what's your point the first
one you fell in love with this man came
on screen and said that you could plant
a tree and at the end of the game come
back and it's grown yeah
easy to sit there I could sell you the
craziest stuff in the world if I lie
about everything involving it mm-hmm
so what's your thoughts this is your
Legend I mean I I hope I hope he's being
sincere and you know he's learned his
lessons from what he did in the Fable
franchise but most likely he he's a
snake car salesman still so you know he
he can easily sell stuff because
obviously when you come out there and
you you over promise and under deliver
it's easy to sell stuff
but
can you keep that retention and that
audience still loves you and they trust
you that's the question and I don't I
don't know if he's learned from that
list last question I have to ask you
this with the new Fable being announced
playground has it he I don't want him
nothing
you don't want him to continue
to consult on it I I actually would for
him not to even be in the same building
Fable was being made
he'll walk around and like that bad juju
would start spreading to the other
people there it's like no like like
Peter you got something else going stay
away from favor you you had your chance
with Fable to yourself you over promised
and under delivered it's like he went
and talked to the engineers yo I think
this would be cool and then she's like
well let me see if I can do that and he
just went straight outside you know this
is not all this is what we're doing like
you know he got he what kind of Doom
playground we do I mean lion we heard
the history there was a mutiny I heard
from developers they're trying to get
him up out of there because they didn't
it got so crazy for my understanding
listen to the story was that
Xbox had to send PR people around with
him everywhere he go because of the over
feature promising and then I heard it
with lying like there was a mutiny they
all left because they were just getting
tired of when it comes to when PR is
heavily evolved you got people like the
dude who plays Spider-Man where he can't
keep his mouth shut he constantly be
spoiling stuff so they got to make sure
you got people that play Doctor Strange
going on there and have he answers his
questions for him he looks at him before
he answers the question he got people
like Peter Peter Rock and Liberty they
sent him there is because it's not
because he's spoiling stuff it's because
he lying about spoiling about stuff
so you got to keep that he says
something he looks at me he's like no
that's not what's happening here
um an experimental thing in the in the
development process we're not promising
that's there we hope that's there but
we're not promising that there and here
comes Peter just walking out of nowhere
no we're promising and not only is it
gonna be there but it's going to be
better than ever all right two comments
I gotta interrupt before you open it up
said addict said Peter is spraying his
bad juju on other developers pause and
then lost away he says come over he said
attic Talking Like Fable one and two
with trash what's wrong with you no
Fable one is the best Fable not two
games no it's not now Fable one is the
best thing was okay well Fable one is
the best thing
I I got no issue with what his
involvement it's just like look man like
when you when you give
you know coming off of like the jokeness
and being serious like even if they
offered him like you know
you know we he's gonna consult on on the
new direction that ever Faith was going
in it's like I want PR on this dude I
want his emails being looked at 24 7. I
want every time someone asked to do an
interview them they're like I gotta get
with Microsoft and playground games like
it's like this stupid problem with the
dude yeah and say you want 24 hours
surveillance it's either it's either let
the dude ride
I don't think he was bad for the Fable
franchise I think his Antics and how his
mind it's like it's like he lost his
mind towards the end of the Fable
franchise it's like how are you gonna
promise some of the most outlayish
things in existence and clearly I didn't
know but he's promised it in other games
whatever that game you were talking
about so it's just like dude like there
is a such thing that's equivalent to
Microsoft going out there and Aaron gray
bird and say we got Fable for you we got
Perfect Dark gameplay Fable gameplay a
vowed oh that's coming out next week oh
you guys want to see Halo 9 well we
skipped six six and seven we coming
straight out with nine and then when it
comes out what happened Peter I don't
know
but my point is is when you over promise
you gotta at least be some realm of that
realistic expectation and Peter was just
shooting through the Stars it's like be
going out making sure it's a very sunny
no Cloud day and he just shooting all
his shots up in the air
never attention of grabbing none of this
stuff
it is what it is
oh my God now I gotta have a poll what
fables the best continue all right all
right your thoughts for this um
new game outside this this guy here
I got to go back to black and white okay
I was so in this is when I was like okay
dude and I was I was playing the PC
so heavy and I'm like yo um he's talking
about black and white coming out and
black and white didn't live up to its
expectations then
um Cog and I got a chance to we were
heavily in on connect connect 360.
because hey King King vote in the poll
all right that poll is rigged he didn't
even pick him up
what the the stuff that they were
talking about and the stuff that was
going on was beyond me
and to bold face get up there and lie
right and then to come out years later
and talk about oh how now yours just
tricked yeah
you and Tripp Hawkins hold a special
place in my heart
y'all are the best salesman
to ever hit this Earth trip was a beast
you know but Tripp Hawkins himself
that M2 oh yeah whatever he built with
that 3DO come on legendary
what he did with that M2 okay he went to
bed I agree I'm too we was there we was
there we saw I think that thing I think
the graphics still looked better than
Ray Trace stuff I mean and to be fair to
be fair King it could have been one of
those things where you know that was
stuff that he originally intended on
being on the board when it comes to
making these games and then it just got
ultimately cut but it's just like even
if that's the case like don't over there
and talk about the most far-fetched
features that you could put in a game
and then sell the game on those features
and then not those features not only
King are those features not in the game
there's nothing that resembles those
features in the game no it's it's not
that and the reason why I brought up
trip Hawkins is because
they are snake oil salesmen damn they
will pretty up something
in order to sell you don't know his
Ultimate Game his back door was the cell
trip Hawkins ultimate back door was to
sell M2
and he sold it and we got it inside
microwaves and all other stuff other
than what we deserve to get it in and
that the charlatan did his thing I love
you but you did me dirty I sat there in
front of you and you did me dirty yeah
did the same thing we asked what was it
special access New York oh God we had we
had that's the first time we had a
spread remember we went and they had a
spread of food we sat in the theater
yeah what what was it what was it uh um
Rockefeller Center
no Carney was Carnegie Hall we sat
inside conical Hall and remember that's
where the Rockettes go with their little
legs remember we said
yeah they had all that stuff there and
they pulled the curtain up they did all
that he talked to us and he lied to our
face right and Peter did the same thing
we were so open on the connect and he
fooled Microsoft and this was his back
door I'm gonna push this in your face
while I'm selling the company to
Microsoft
and I'm out of here
so you never got project Nadal you never
you never got it you never got Milo
which was the most amazing thing that
was selling the connect if that would
have ever came out in that form to
connect with the soul billions we would
all we wouldn't have controllers right
now with the stuff that they was talking
about but this is how you sell a company
so now I guess the Microsoft and I'm not
going to disrespect your wallet because
I don't care because I know your wallet
is bigger than mine yo your resume is
bigger than mine I don't make video
games I just play them and I listen to
individuals like yourself sell me on the
next game that you're going with to
bring but you can't sell me a
Lamborghini with a Volvo engine
and think I'm going to buy another car
for me you know what's crazy King he's
made some crazy
promises so bad he has his own topic on
our show today explain that to me right
now well I'm explaining that I'm not
buying this game this game got to come
out and show improve features yeah Peter
send me a review code uh send me a
review code and king of TCL TV at the
[__]
and you're winning the Pokemon no it's
just this is
you can't
sell somebody junk and expect them to
buy from you again
or lie to them and expect them to trust
you your fan base is only going to go as
far as your last delivery right if you
have a bad service and something goes
wrong if you buy from GrubHub you buy
from doordash and you have a bad service
you might be reluctant in doing it again
you might say it's a one-off you try
again this is not the first time that he
has over promise under delivered and for
me it started with black and white my
populace was dope I was playing populous
so when he said we doing black and white
I'm like all right it took years for
this game to come out when it did come
out it was absolutely broken it was
absolutely broken so the lies that you
built started with me there then you go
over here then I'm like what the hell is
going on then the promises you made him
Fable let's not look at you made good
great games but the promises that was in
there that game would have been God's
hair it's not it's just a really good
game right so now it's God to and if you
have the guy that sit here and love
Fable so much that got him into gaming
telling you that you lied to me I love
this franchise but stay the hell away
from it bro I'm not buying your game
that's just it fair enough feel very
passionate I can feel it project that's
all the legend table yeah he that that's
the one that uh people in the chat vote
in the poll continue made me upset back
in the day was the whole project natal
thing because that thing was pretty huge
for us Gamers you know to see that level
of interaction with an NPC essentially
uh through this camera device and
everything it looked incredible and you
thought man this is where Gaming's going
this is amazing and no no never never
happened
um I look Fable and and uh again he made
promises within Fable that never
happened the whole you can plant a tree
grow it in the game it'll be a full tree
no no didn't happen uh there was a lot
of didn't happens with with this guy
um and if you read the direct quote in
the Articles he says that he stumbled
upon him mechanic that Gamers haven't
seen before and I'm thinking first of
all how do you stumble upon a mechanic
and then he goes on to promise
then this is going to be a fresh
experience for gamers
I don't think so I think this is another
case of Peter overselling and he's going
to definitely under deliver here
um it will be a game that is something
akin to what he's made in the past we're
going to get fable-like or whatever and
it may even be a good game but I don't
trust this Charlotte
speaker more than I trust him
breaking up with your ex and they come
back and they say y'all gonna do better
I'm gonna be different this time I'll be
crazy if you don't be crazy
you'll be crazy if like he actually does
meet expectations and keeps his word on
everything but then he gets them so yeah
you'll be crazy too if like his like it
doesn't meet the expectations he had in
his head because he actually was
truthful about stuff and didn't over
promise so he couldn't like sell the
game as much as he would want
I think you bringing up King uh trip
Hawkins and you know look all these old
cats that I think that was the style of
business yeah back in the day I think I
think the over promising was huge in
this industry yeah
um it really was because I mean it's
it's rare that you hear any of these
guys come out and say you know this is
what we're promising and then they
deliver I mean outside of uh what's his
name that created um uh you know Mario
and all that stuff
my Amato yeah back in the day that he
delivered on whatever he promised with
these games for his consumers and I
think I think that's a testament to why
Nintendo is still intent of today and
they they really do things for their
Gamers because they're still even
innovating within their own games they
may not be the graphical powerhouses
that you I want kids yeah it's crazy
yeah but what you can do within these
games the mechanics that they're using
in the games they are expanding there
they are innovating and they're doing
different things Peter on the other hand
I don't see him doing anything creative
uh
man it it sucks to say that because as a
gamer you want these developers to
innovate and create special things but
you have to look at the background and
history of these people that are saying
this and history tells me don't believe
this guy yeah
do you think
he thought his absence was was was uh
far enough that people forgot what he
did the last time you know when somebody
steal from your house you don't see him
no I think I think his I think his ego
trumps that I think his ego is I'm still
Peter molyneux and these people are
still going to listen to me no matter
what you know I I I've never heard this
guy like come out and I know you said
that there was a TED talk or something
yeah but I personally never seen him
come out and like uh apologize for what
he under delivered on or anything I I I
think he stands by his word even though
that word is total
but he stands that's a good point I
think to your point that's where a lot
of people have the issues with him and
it's it's ownership or deflecting and
then obviously there was there was this
game called Goddess that was um
like a Kickstarter game after he left
the lion hunt thing and then you know
there was a lot of overpromising there
and then people it was like PC and
mobile then the mobile game was getting
more of the stuff and PC was and people
were getting really upset and yeah a lot
of people claim you know they were
shortchanged in that situation plus a
lot of his games it kind of feels it
didn't resonate with me I didn't like
dungeon keepers I don't like black and
white I didn't think it was very good
um yeah
because I remember when that game came
yeah it seems like he's good at writing
a studio just not good at anything PR
related like at all like oh no yeah let
someone else go up there and explain
your game don't do it yourself I mean
this time he said he's got to change
that normally I would tell y'all
everything about the game and over you
know with the free he's like I'm not
gonna do that I'm just going to wait to
show you guys okay then you know maybe
he has learned his lesson but maybe he
don't know what to say about his game
now right now like because remember he
stumbled upon us
that's what jumped out I stumbled upon
this mechanic The Gamers haven't seen
before and I'm like BS
what if all he's been playing was God of
War and he found a jump button
listen to court before I give it to
pause before I go I'm saying King you're
saying he was speaking to PlayStation
folks when he talked about a mechanic
they haven't seen oh the TCL dude 1080p
we're getting a fire basically he says
um the game is the first game really
that he's coded or been colder on since
black and white he says so it makes it
very special oh no
it's been evolving and we've been
exploring ideas about it for almost five
years so it's very very close to his
heart I think you add a d under that
word devolving
and once you feel black and white you
left me right there
I I hope the best man I hope the best
I'm not I'm not I love that I hope very
I'm not very optimistic on the outcome
of that but I hope he does well and it's
like you know
me me personally
just stay off of Twitter don't take
interviews keep yourself in your studio
with the doze locks and letting someone
else adequately it sounds like he just
broke up with a woman he's telling her
giving her rules stay away from me don't
come near me
don't know it's it's worse fonts you're
saying don't come near me I'm saying
Don't Go Near anyone oh man that's good
for anybody yeah
I think it's Milo
he said I think he gotta connect he
still got to connect he's just like I'm
gonna deliver gonna reinvented put a wig
on Milo and say it's brand new oh look
you know what's crazy cyber in the chat
makes a good point Fable is better is a
better game because uh having never
watched a Peter interview prior yeah let
me get let me get pockets for the
closest yeah the legend is back outside
just to clarify we need 190 like setups
we driving man we drive let's go
listen uh Peter ball uh yes yes I gotta
I gotta respect the history of what he's
done right I gotta respect that
absolutely one thousand percent there's
a butt here somewhere
of course they're always going to be
with any good snake oils man you know
your snoke oil salesman you're gonna get
this but the fact is is
what no you're gonna get a butt uh
listen [__] ah there we go
um but with populists populous theme
park Dungeon Keeper
um Fable obviously again I gotta respect
the man for what he's done and I I love
people that have huge dreams and
Ambitions because they can push things
forward however there is a point where
you should not speak those dreams and
Ambitions unless you know that you have
the potential to hit them right it's one
thing to
you know Dream Out Loud like hey
wouldn't it be great if we can pull this
off and we could do this it's another
thing to get up in front of a room a
crowd your your future customers media
you know your bosses and everybody else
and say no we're going to have this and
then it never shows up again right I am
still upset to this day we never got
Milo right I thought Milo was the
greatest thing bro I mean again again
blew my mind and obviously we now know
there's a reason why right because stage
two the stage right so so but the the
fact is is that
we need people that are big dreamers
obviously that's our main part of this
industry so I'm not gonna down Peter
Molino for having dreams or hopes or or
Ambitions to try to push things forward
in different directions in some of his
previous games a lot of his previous
games are high water marks
um and not everybody in his position can
say that they put out that many games
that were that quality yes he's had his
misses as well that's going to happen in
this industry but again once you've
spoken this many times and been proven
this many times to be a huckster right
to be
so do you see that guy right to to be
that ultimate salesman who is willing to
go to the point of lying flat out right
about what you've got going on behind
the scenes then no everybody should not
care a thing that you say until you
prove differently until you've proven
that you've learned your lesson until
you've proven that what you are
currently working on is actually
something different and you bring that
out to the masses and we're all able to
get our hands on it you should stay
quiet from this point on and nobody
should believe what you've got to say
until you actually show the proof in the
pudding so uh that's where I'm at with
Peter Molino again I again I gotta
respect the man from what he has done
but what he said I'm not going to
respect all that now at this point now
that we know the truth nah I'm not I'm
not gonna give us Milo damn it right
Milo
so there it is I thought it was an
interesting for what I wish Saul was
here for this one I would love his uh
perspective on it but yeah the The
Legend I guess we got to see you know
what what it comes out and what's this
game breaking feature and what it does
for the industry man
that he didn't want to fix that he
turned into but we got it
I I I still even though the over
promising undelivery Yes Y'all right
you can't tell me this bag can sell
water to a world like when he get
excited about the project
yeah his interviewers are legendary
everybody's buying it though we got to
the point where we know Pinocchio
we see the strings
what if he don't got it like this is
years later I don't believe him I'm
trying to remember this we are from the
old school generation of Gamers to where
we know Peter molyneux we we know what
what he said in the past uh we know what
he's done and not done
um there's a lot of new school Gamers
out there that don't know any of this so
they see this and go fresh mechanic oh
this guy's amazing
totally awesome and then it's gonna come
out and it's gonna be you know like you
said a bug or something or whatever he's
transformed into a mechanic
I need to test some stuff with um one of
my guests and stuff behind the scenes
but anyway uh I had a great time with
you guys today I am down anytime you
want me to come by I'll swing on by I I
love rocking with you guys I miss solved
today it solves my single player homie
miss him uh but it was great the chat
awesome as usual you ain't even read
that I don't know if I could have
handled yeah yeah they double together
would have been oh he was the perfect
guy to have on and SOB's affluence yeah
I mean solved would have said the same
things yeah for sure but anyways shout
out to you guys shout out to the chat
and uh if anybody wants to swing by
fawn's Gaming later on uh I've got my
show coming up later on uh swing on by
games talk live
and I will have
I didn't know pong was going to be on
this show but I have him scheduled on
myself
along with a map from fun speculations
okay absolutely everybody go salute put
the links in his channel go check them
out go go subscribe good content and
some of the best five questions ever
even though he get too crazy yes that
was fun I love you brother I appreciate
good to see you always love Brothers
voice in the business greatest voice of
the bit isn't doing things behind the
scenes but we ain't gonna talk about
that
buzz I appreciate you brother
appreciation
[Music]
oh Lord
five dollar super trap from Angry hippie
the Lord's needed an Arby's sponsor IOP
we got the beef we got them yes beefy
two dollars from Lloyd Metro Peter sat
with Todd yo this is how you guys now go
don't come on Todd like that
five dollars from Domer Sports I play
game pass directly on my phone I gotta
controller just saying playing Star foot
on Game Pass Via mobile phone might be
lit stay blessed yeah I can see that
yeah we we like a hundred and like
attic could you go on please
that's not gonna happen that's it okay
cool that's it
bye
so we're gonna get into the final topic
here um
this is King's topic uh shout out to uh
Bloomberg and uh you know what's funny
we met this gentleman at E3
I'm gonna get my blessing key if you
want to bring back out Bring bucket
appreciate it
anyway Takashi I always butcher his
nasty muchuzuki but anyway we met he was
actually next to his attic during the
Xbox showcase uh writing an article
while we was in the um thing but anyway
salute to him Square Enix new Final
Fantasy 16 sales decreased compared to
the first week uh for mitsu estimates a
90 drop in sales from the first week of
release sluggish worldwide and he says
unable to increase sales further with
without significant price Cuts as an
expert so it goes on to say that Final
Fantasy 16 which was released on June
22nd by Major Game Giant Square Enix
Holdings are sluggish it seems the
sluggish stock price movement will will
be spurred he goes on to talk about the
volume of the uh the unit sold you know
from that second week which was 37 000
uh units in the second week next year
ridiculous it's decreased by 90 which
was for about 336 000 in the previous
week
the stat statistics do not include sales
of digital versions and then pretty much
he just said that um you know as far as
in comparison to you know Past final
fantasies you know Final Fantasy 15 was
uh after the second week was about 72
000 and basically you know just saying
that um you know this was a difficult
basically the Analyst at uh Toyo
security said this was a difficult
result and it will be impossible to
increase sales any further unless the
price is significantly lowered he said
he points out that most of the failure
is a result of the advanced publicity
I'm assuming demo and the fact that the
actual game itself is too far removed
from the Final Fantasy of the past
leaving consumers behind so this is
King's topic he wanted to talk about
sales in Final Fantasy so sir explain to
me your thoughts here oh man so we got
game of the year Contender Final Fantasy
16. it was all good just a week
nothing too short
until digital found you care about the
water and a cold blanket on your neck
and the seals decided to tank
oh is this your king
the 720 Master
this is yo y'all wanted so Square how I
feel being a first party to a failing
console what's up bro like it's I
thought y'all brought games
I thought you had supported the devs
this is the moment where you need to
disappoint him the most he's going down
he chose you but you did not choose him
like you he said I do and you said I
don't
y'all are not supporting what's going on
I thought this was the greatest Final
Fantasy I thought this was fantastic
it's a PlayStation exclusive it's
exclusively failing because you guys
don't buy games 30 something thousand
bro I'm playing the game how you gonna
have the Xbox playing the game and you
ain't I haven't seen no gameplay
trailers from you dudes at all I haven't
seen no gameplay I haven't seen your
retweeting I haven't seen anything from
y'all and you know why because you're
not supporting and this game is gonna
fail because Sony chose them and said
you know what you're gonna be first
party Y'all Gonna Make this game just
for us what about the Xbox platform ah
don't worry about that
oh
you should have been for the streets
this is what happens when you wife up
the dude that don't buy stuff oh they're
really good so so we saying three
billion in one week is failure that's
what we're doing that's what we're doing
that's not Final Fantasy numbers this is
okay so you won't compared to the
obviously okay I'll give you that but
three billion in one week no it is a
failure for them if they're talking
about we need the price cut the game
ain't been out a month and you're
talking about we gotta significantly cut
yo we y'all having a fire seal bro it
just came out the dude ain't it the
body's not cold yet oh man y'all
stuffing them in the ground putting them
in the Bargain Bin so you mean to tell
me I could have waited two weeks and got
the game for half price
how is this making sense your math ain't
mathing bro
this ain't it like this is not it and
y'all keep constantly telling me
PlayStation we out here supporting we
buy the games this is a triple a banger
not by the Numbers B
I just want to know how everybody else
feel about the failure of squares higher
ups deciding to choose to make this game
a PlayStation 5 exclusive and it's
turning around to tear them up you
should have gave it to everybody maybe
you could have doubled your shells and
don't have to be in a fire sale should
have put it on switch oh man
the Final Fantasy 16 uh sales situation
well like King just said if you're going
to choose to put it on one platform and
one platform only then this is the
numbers you can probably expect again
I'm not gonna say it's a failure but
obviously Square internally may but
again they are the ones who took the bag
like King just said they're the ones who
made that decision so as with every
other problem that square is currently
facing and has faced it all comes down
to those decision makers right at the
end of the day like I said in the
beginning of the show when we talked
about this a little bit as far as the
game itself again from the outside
looking in somebody who hasn't touched
it yet I am going to play it eventually
when it comes to PC but
um the fact that right exactly the fact
is that the fact is is that just from
watching all the gameplay I have
listening to people that have talked you
know that have played it that are
talking to people it is different from
Final Fantasy in a lot of directions
that people don't necessarily approve of
again you can try new things in final
fantasies always try new things you can
do that but this is the risk you run
alienating parts of your fan base right
this is the risk that you always will
take if you move too far away from what
it means to be a Final Fantasy game and
how people Define that then this is what
you can you know have happen where you
can have big the initial sales three
million one week great that's your
hardcore fan base that's your fan base
going out loving whatever you're gonna
slap Final Fantasy on we're going to buy
that right we're ready
but then after that where's the legs
yeah
right that's right
where's the legs the legs are going to
be all the other people that are on the
fence or all the people that are like
well I love I like Final Fantasy but I'm
not always sure about you know what but
maybe I'll get one down the road that's
your legs but if you come out the gate
and you show yourself and people are out
here talking and not every yes there's a
lot of people saying game of the year
and all that that's fine it's an opinion
it is what it is some people are gonna
really like it but a lot of people are
saying well if you're expecting classic
Final Fantasy if you're expecting big
RPG elements this isn't the game for you
if you like Devil May Cry well maybe you
want to try it because the combat's good
well not everybody's on board with that
right not everybody's in favor of that
so then those people stay on the fence
or those people say nope just not the
Final Fantasy for me so then you see the
stagnation of sales almost immediately
and we've seen this in other games not
just it's not just Final Fantasy we see
this all the time but the the fact is
that square has made decisions that have
limited to Their audience more and more
and more they are putting themselves
into a corner with no way out they are
so heavily Reliant in so many different
ways on that Sony bag uh time and time
again that they are
here now like where we only get the PS5
version how much better would have sold
had been on PC day one as well right
even if you're going to skip Xbox just
say PC maybe another million maybe
another two million copies right now all
of a sudden we're talking Final Fantasy
15 numbers again right five nights Brian
what are you talking about they don't
need no one else but right they don't
need anything they buy games they
support games right but the install base
on the PlayStation 5 isn't that high yet
either right again you're talking about
a different release schedule than
previous final fantasies you are limited
to what the PlayStation 5 fan base is
going to give you that's three million
and then 30 000. right so that that's
that's where you're sitting at now so
again for me
I'm still interested in this game I've
been interested game game looks gorgeous
everything I've seen I'm really down for
this type of game and I think it'll be
great but for a lot of people I just
don't think it's the Final Fantasy they
wanted and again it's just not going to
have that long-term play that a lot of
Final Fantasy games do I think this is
going to be something that either you
bought it and you loved it or you stayed
away and you're probably going to stay
away because you know the game's not
changing right it is what it is at this
point right so I think that's where I'm
at with it
or addict your thoughts Final Fantasy 16
sales
analytics analytics talking about it and
you know some people saying okay what
I hate I I hate for us to have to do
this to them
we told you so all right Final Fantasy
16 wasn't Final Fantasy it's a fun game
it's an enjoyable game
but as far as a Final Fantasy game
it's not one of those it falls short on
almost every area every Department of
this game almost falls short because
it's not a Final Fantasy game it is a
nice cinematic movie it you know it's
one of those things where it's like can
I have some gameplay with my cinema sir
wow wow that's what we're doing that's
what it feels like bro it's not a game
with your Contender to me but it is an
enjoyable experience I I have enjoyed
playing it I do feel like it's got a a
decent narrative
pretty pretty and that's because of the
presentation the way they showed it you
know if you just want to come in there
play something and just have some
halfway decent combat because it guys
does got fun combat you know I don't I
wouldn't say it's like in depth or
anything like that but it is fun combat
it's game it's for you but if you want
what that
that beginning part the Final Fantasy
part
probably not and it's definitely not a
console seller you know it's it's a
solid experience that you can go in
there get about 20 30 hours of solid
game play well some gameplay and you can
have a very well told story here's the
thing though
I might be joking about the like the
amount of cinematics in here but I don't
mind that much as long as it's told well
and the narrative is is is good enough
to where I want to see the cut scenes
there's nothing worse than seeing cut
scenes you don't want to see
because that means you're not interested
in the story you don't care what's going
on in the sport you just want to get to
the gameplay the story of this game
captivates you where you want to see the
next major cut scene now when they're
talking about yo go go ahead and do the
side activities I skip on all right I
don't I don't watch none of that do you
think because it was alluded to in the
article that the overexposure and the
demo uh probably uh tainted the pool of
the game and left the um
the the less uh ambiguous nature of the
game uh it was just too much to be seen
of the game do you think that they
didn't have anything for surprise for
anybody else
do you think that affected it the
overexposure because we saw it
before the show at the show and then the
demo
I actually felt like the demo is the
only reason the game sold three million
already
um
it was a very impressive demo and if you
wouldn't have had that demo and you went
off of Final Fantasy fans explaining
their hype for the game I don't think it
would have sold as much because it would
have been you know me as a final fantasy
fan I went into it already side eyed or
why are you focusing so much on these
these summons you know why are you
putting so much of the concentration on
these summons I've said from day one
they spend too much time on presentation
and not enough time on what makes the
world the world and the way it's the
gameplay unique to other Final Fantasy
games they spent so much time on the
audience fighting in this war sure it's
a lit story and that concept's cool
where's the rest of the game it's like
they took so long and so much money you
you've seen you've played uh so uh the
ldm battles how much money do you think
that cost a lot yeah and once they do
that five or six times I don't know how
many times they fought I kind of dropped
the game so like the second time already
I'm gonna pick it back up but
spent all that money on these these
in-depth very attractive looking fights
but realistically after doing three of
them
they they are very very well done qte
yes it felt like Pan's a Dragoon wow it
felt like he was on Rails and the first
battle that I did when he was flying
around and you're the Phoenix and you're
shooting Biomat
um
the same way like um
you like passive Dragon you felt so you
felt like like very odd rails High
cinematic it was a high cinematic on
real shooter that's what exactly what it
felt like it didn't it tried to do
something different and I and I
understand that in every in every game
you want to try something different to
get a different hook but some things
that are innately inherent inside a a
certain title needs to be there
things are like I get what you're saying
they are valid but these are like some
of the best cinematics we've ever seen
in game like it is this is like like set
pieces bro like this is oh my God this
is happening type situation I mean I
don't want to give credit on that that's
what attic I'm sorry you know he muted
his mic for a second but um no I mean if
he didn't you know he didn't finish then
I was gonna jump in look you know from a
I don't think 3 million is a
disappointment but I do agree
comparatively to other final fantasies
yes then they have not reached their own
internal Target you know um the day that
may have resonated was actually the
Japanese analyst saying what addict is
saying about moving away from a
traditional Final Fantasy being a factor
in that he actually he kind of that
statement I don't know what when I read
that statement to me it's like almost
calls out the demo because he goes this
is a very difficult result and it will
be impossible to increase sales any
further unless the price is lowered okay
we get that but he goes He points out
that most of the failure is a result of
the advanced publicity if I'm reading
this correctly only Advanced publicity
I'm looking at is the demo so it's
almost like the demo is the gift of the
curse because there were people like
myself who was on the fence about it
played the devil was like yo this is lit
but according to the you know Japanese
and famitsu they felt the other way like
almost like oh this is not traditional
Final Fantasy I'm I'm a I'm a I'm a
pushback yo please do please do only to
say because it was ambiguous with the
whole uh wording of advanced publicity
right right yeah exactly I might say
this we always said that they showed too
much of this game
that's a good point
I don't think I don't think that's
what's hurting it though I generally
think you have a you have a a domino
effect you know us as consumers we're
also content creators so we kind of have
to try the game to some degree
but to a consumer to a consumer let's
say my friend Nathan my friend and my
friend John Nathan buys the game yo this
isn't Final Fantasy fam John doesn't buy
the game right see when I buy the game I
got to because I got to try the game out
to give those initial Impressions off
but when you have that Chain Reaction
you have those initial people that
picked up day one that this what's going
on here this game's not getting so word
of mouth it's getting so strictly off
marketing right because when it gets
sold off word of mouth it's going to
pick up faster now it's like I said
people in the chat's like addict it
sounds like you I do like the game but I
can still criticize and say this isn't a
Final Fantasy game it's like I felt on
breath of the volunteers of the Kingdom
great game bad Zelda game but the way I
found a Fallout 4 great game bad Fallout
game not get it I I do I still think
King's Point resonates though because I
we got to be real like they prior to
this game releasing and prior to the
demo they were like too short and to the
point where even PlayStation core fans
were upset that they showed it again
with the level of depth at the Showcase
people were like yo we kind of knew
already and even that first showing was
super in-depth they showed yeah they had
a whole half an hour yeah it shows so
much of the game that's actually a good
point it could be Advanced publicity
could be that and maybe as people peel
the layers back from a hardcore Japanese
perspective they say okay you know what
they're saying the Final Fantasy we're
used to and maybe that in Japan why we
have such the the second you know week
drop off which is extremely significant
or could it be a bigger no more
nefarious thought that I had it was the
nefarious the fact that um Sony has
abandoned Japan and Japan has abandoned
Sony
I mean it it is interesting maybe that's
raising PlayStation abandoned them those
because they went strictly more towards
the mobile market and it's harder to
sell their products there switches
their PlayStation 5 is a huge baby yeah
yeah it's just big big yeah no listen I
get where you're going and then
obviously the background and the whole
you know more of a European kind of feel
Game of Thrones coming on what happened
yo I was gonna take the Wings off mine
and play my final fantasy with a naked
anyway look that's all I got on it but
it was interesting to see these comments
and these information but uh yeah you
know what I was looking for you because
because Cog he's like you know you got
to get your arms and shoulders bigger so
I'm too uh my my ability to to broadened
and I have my own workout I was I was
looking for some you know some some
loose weights I mean you know I don't
need that
um
yeah I already feel the burn I want to
be beefy let's go
you're showing us your bills huh if you
turn it on it works as a a tanning
machine anyway
shout out to Alex shout out the phone
and of course pong soul in the building
where can I find people find you what
you got going on Sir absolute pleasure
uh thank you again for the invite always
honored and humbled to drop on in here
with you uh in the realm uh chat you
guys are absolutely incredible the
weekend week out this is one of the best
places to be if you're in chat man from
the beginning uh and I didn't get to say
anything in the beginning but everything
you guys have done
screw the jealousy man yeah whatever
whatever that's human nature man what
you guys have done the hard work that
you put in Second To None you deserve
everything all the accolades and more at
this point so continue to do what you
guys do you don't need here for me but I
need to tell you guys because you guys
are an inspiration uh to me jumping into
the podcast scene originally
um and I've been watching you guys you
know since almost the beginning when I
jumped first in the chat so thank you
thank you for all that uh again you guys
do it right for sure so um but uh
absolutely everybody you can find me
punk sell Xbox pencil on Twitter you
guys know the drill there
um otherwise you know Thursday nights
it's PM in the PM Pawn you have in the
p.m on Thursday night 7 P.M Eastern six
o'clock Central Time fun speculations
Channel back on fun speculation Channel
Friday night's Xbox ultimate 10 p.m
Eastern nine o'clock Central Time and
then Saturday mornings we get you
started live Raw and Uncut whoa my
brother steel and I still rain and I we
go live 10 a.m Eastern nine o'clock
Central Time living split screen split
screens all word every Saturday morning
three plus hours we just did 4 45 I
think on Saturday so uh just him and I
had it up oh yeah we love the talk so uh
we're gonna be there every Saturday and
then Sunday nights it's the shot podcast
ptk oh damn one of the best hosts in the
business by far been doing it for a long
time fuzzy Belle with your and myself at
least you have a guess yeah absolutely
we have a good time there 9pm Eastern
eight o'clock Central time otherwise
everybody it's been an extreme pleasure
to be here uh listen it's golden age of
gaming folks it really is Best Time Ever
to be a gamer right now so get out there
play what you love love what you play
No Doubt Punk so the legend no doubt we
put the link in the description for his
channel his chat is you know chapter 120
he got all his information in solo3 vid
in there saying yeah let's go let's go
no doubt salute man always love to how
you love your energy brother love what
you bring the positivity and um just
your game and knowledge your passion for
it it really radiates and so much
respect for you glad you answered the
call of the realm I was hoping I'd get
another rematch last time I know it
worked out schedule I think it was
Easter something yeah it was Easter yeah
yeah yeah
but Salute You Paul appreciate you buddy
thank you for the comments it really
really means a lot man no doubt so what
I'm going to do before we do our outros
um King I forgot remember we gotta do
the poll this time because forgot the
poll last week so we're gonna do this
poll get this ready so this was this was
what was going to be last week if XBox
wins the case against the FTC to stop
the preliminary injunction for the ABK
deal how do you think PlayStation should
respond
the choices are a continue to make
strategic third-party deals exclusive
for PlayStation consoles B develop your
own multiplayer live service games to
compete with Cod
C continue making quality first party
games and improve PS Plus
or D I don't care we gonna double up
with the CBA CMA to block this damn deal
but King says adapter become an app
it was actually boss that was dope those
are those salute yo we gonna get this
out there this time [__] is not gonna
forget we're gonna put it on Twitter
social media everybody hit that up when
you get a chance against good to see
everybody here attic got a video coming
up next that he's promoting very heavily
and um we want to do the super chats and
then our outros or the outros of the
Super Chat which you wouldn't do it uh
did the outros in the super Chef there's
not too many King is going plague Tails
yeah yeah Requiem yeah you might want to
Ally I see you I see you I see you
moving no doubt Lord attic where can I
find people find you what you got going
on sir
follow me on Twitter the Lord addict IOP
you can find me on YouTube a gaming
addict here's my thumbnail I'm gonna do
the Will Smith
so uh I'm raking all the Xbox Studios uh
blizzard uh blizzard uh Activision
Studios may or may not be in the video
uh I think some of you gonna be really
upset because Cog sound like he was
already getting upset we just telling
them some of my choices yeah but I live
to I live to upset so uh ranking Xbox
Studios I like the thumbnail it's been
me a long time I spent a lot of time on
this video guys I'm going to Premiere uh
the uh the video here in a couple
seconds and I'm going to uh take you
guys over there like I do with uh you
know when we raise people so I
definitely get to that I want to thank
everyone for coming through we had over
a thousand people in here yes I'm gonna
be real with you I didn't expect that
like it's it's it's a real light week
for me so I definitely appreciate it for
coming through let me let me just get
these two super chats real quick yeah
there's not too many
uh okay so ten dollars from Tony
Richards appreciate this you know say
something if you go put money say
something
yeah yeah yeah
two opinionated final five six savior
remains and how much I want another
Astros wrath or dmc6
what is the topic about switch happening
it's best-selling June in the in its
seven year lifetime because of the goat
tears of the Kingdom Cox talk uh
politicking hashtag free Nintendo
Metro call your Nintendo in different
shows Sega call what I do now we
supposed to be good moving on we're
moving on like us to talk about Nintendo
Cable ONE one yeah
okay little male gigolo wow Cog big
little magic Wow all right so uh do your
outro uh I ain't gotta get Kingdom gig
we're gonna find what you got going on
first and foremost I would like to thank
oh no it's Alex for coming
um
you know um support comes from different
areas in life and
um it was a pleasant surprise to see his
level of support you don't know how you
affect people uh you just try to uh be
genuine with people and respect people
and um like that level of support was
fantastic you know the level of support
from the community itself it was a very
realistic in its nature but
very very welcomed
um I respect everything about you guys I
expect respect the thousand people that
showed up I uh respect the the likes I
respect the super chats I respect the
people that are just listening and
sharing it out to a friend
um we work extremely hard and I do
appreciate y'all uh reciprocating that I
want to give a shout out to pawn Soul
yes
um
man the hardest working dude bro he
outside I love I love his his Ascension
because I got a chance to watch his
extension from coming out of the the the
the talking from the chat to moving to
podcasts to being on camera because at
first his camera was the same same thing
looking down into your phone or whatever
and switch boom boom
um you know
him and MAV works I was talking to Cog
about it and I was saying that their
personalities work
I love I love the chemistry with him and
math so much is because they complement
each other absolutely right and there's
a difference between being compatible
with somebody and complimenting somebody
because a complementary uh relationship
goes a whole lot further than being
compatible because where one is
deficient that the other one lifts you
understand so I love everything that you
guys are doing I'm not even gonna lie
you know uh some of my late night
programming when I'm going to bed that
you tune in and I do watch and sometimes
I say stuff in the chat you know because
I'm watching on YouTube from my TV so it
doesn't like pop up like I'm on my phone
but um you know sometimes I do say stuff
but I do appreciate you and I do
appreciate everything that you're doing
and I love it and I love watching the
growth and I love your shelf I don't
care what you say about my stuff behind
me you have robo-touch which I had when
I was younger and you have Voltron back
then you have that controller it's
fantastic I love everything about that
yeah it's fine
bro
um your voice you are magnificent I've
always told you you know camera and he
like I said constructive criticism
funds his breakout moment is when you
know he stepped off the dealer for him
because dealer turned them dudes Out Boy
I'm not even gonna sit here and lie is
the Drake it is and um you know Fonz is
Lil Wayne
Weezy F baby yes man Fonz is he's
impeccable it's from everything and to
know everything that he's gone through
to every from from to what he's
accomplishing
bro I salute you so much so thank you so
much for coming through and everybody
you know make sure you watch out
everything and go over the fans
afterwards
um you can find me on uh my PlayStation
playing Final Fantasy
I don't hate fight on fantasy I actually
like it it's just not a Final Fantasy
game that's for Addison right and if I'm
going to play a game for three hours if
I put in three hours worth of work I
expect at least an hour worth of
gameplay
um I only got 20 minutes
of actual gameplay and the rest of
cinematics so that kind of detaches me
from it right because I wanna I have my
Volari there I want to play out my
controller in my hand
and the PlayStation controller isn't
great on battery life but my battery
life is pretty decent
um I'm gonna be playing some fortnite
and I'm going to be on Twitter I'm going
to be talking to Young dread uh about
getting uh beefy Cog um you're going to
be consultant
you're not finalizing anything
okay but you know leave it in your hands
I got something I got some visions and I
think those Visions will pan out I got
[__] too that I'll make the final
decision on with my eyes though yes sir
yes yes because you know what your voice
is we let you know
are y'all gonna get the beefy
I already know where you're going you
know what you know what king Cox should
let Alex do the phone no no no no no no
no he already went left I think it
should be a wrestling belt right and it
should be over here like like you know
beefy
Alex had them put in meeting in the chat
it was crazy yeah
absolutely
you know what it is Yo um fun show I'm
glad everybody came out I didn't expect
to talk about it but we talked about
what we talked about and uh Lords Duke
Brown
gotta throw a party for my day ones they
ain't in the studio over there lay some
yo I'm just blessed I'm blessed you know
sometimes I don't even have to say
anything and it just the hard work and
the grind it means something and at the
end of the day don't let anyone take
away from the hard work you put in and
everybody knows it it's like so I'm not
gonna go too deep in it because like I
always feel like what's authentic and
what's truly authentic doesn't need to
be explained y'all know it's real here
everyone knows who I am what we are what
we represent I don't have to go back and
forth with anyone so at the end of the
day we're gonna move in love you know
what I'm saying if we go further
hopefully it don't and this is where
it's at and I'm cool you know I'm saying
but I've already got a ton of messages
sorry if I was distracted this uh
episode a lot of people were hitting me
up behind the scenes but it's all love
goon stand down I see the goons the
shooters on Deck stand down as we moving
with love but I just want to say thank
you I really sometimes you need to see
it when you go through something you
need to see it who who's really
riding who's really appreciative you
know what I mean and I try my best to be
a good person that's all I could do I
try my best to be a good person I try my
best to celebrate everybody if you are a
QA tester if you're a dude that just did
Voice or the game if you're a dude
that's just PR for the game or whatever
you're an executive I I'll give you a
voice that's what we always been with
the whole idea
the whole idea of iron Lords is you are
a lord in your realm and we're going to
celebrate you so this is celebrating
games that's what it is we don't let
nobody stop the mission it's all love
you know what I'm saying regardless and
that's pretty much it and y'all having
too much fun with this beefy team we
gonna go that's all I got that's all I
got it's all good he said We Ready for
War [__] anyways nah Stand Down stand
down when you guys shoot nobody but it's
all good I love it
keep that beef seasoned I know that's
all I got anything else anybody else got
we've rolled up out of here we good yo
everybody enjoy peace and love yeah I'm
sending you guys over to my video
[Music]
foreign